Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Brittlar und heute ist der 4. November.
Einundzwanzig und ähm ja, ihr werdet's schon äh ahnen. Heute gibt's wieder mal ein Corona-Wickli, was ja.
Schon seit einiger Zeit nicht mehr ganz so weakly ist, aber äh das ignorieren wir jetzt einfach mal. Alle anderen Regeln werden ja auch äh weitgehend ignoriert in diesem Lande. Ich sage erstmal hallo zu Pavel, hallo.
Hallo, Tim.
Genau und ähm ja diesmal haben wir uns auch ein bisschen vorbereitet.
Nicht, dass wir uns nicht sonst auch vorbereiten würden, aber extra nochmal gestern in Ruhe zusammengesessen, um mal so ein bisschen
rüberzufühlen, was eigentlich grade so Phase ist und wollen heute mal wieder versuchen,
wenig die Gesamtpandemische Lage,
zusammenzufassen und ich habe so den Eindruck, wir haben uns einen ganz guten Zeitpunkt gewählt.
Schlechten, je nachdem, wie man's so deutet, denn ja, die vierte Welle kommt jetzt grade, heute mal so richtig in Schwung.
Darüber wollen wir ähm sprechen.
Vielleicht nochmal eine kurze Hausmeisterei äh vorweg wer diesen Kanal abonniert hat, wird festgestellt haben, dass äh ich hier so einen kleinen Zwischenruf in den Kanal gegossen habe mit der,
Bitte an dem Hinweis, ähm wenn ihr,
schon äh Unterstützerinnen der Metaebene seid. Dann hat sich leider, leider, leider wieder einmal,
ähm das Spendenkonto geändert und von daher äh möchte ich euch bitten, wenn ihr einen Dauerauftrag laufen habt, den entsprechend umzustellen.
Und wenn ihr keinen habt, dann könnt ihr doch mal drüber nachdenken, ob das nicht eine tolle Sache wäre, damit die Mieterebene äh auch weiterhin so frequent äh on air sein kann, wie sie das äh bisher war.
Alle Informationen dazu findet ihr auf Mitterebene ME Slash Spenden und da gibt's dann auch,
sonstigen Optionen, wenn euch solche Bankdaueraufträge in irgendeiner Form nicht liegen oder nicht geeignet äh scheiden. Dann gibt's auch noch andere Optionen.
Ja, vielen Dank auf jeden Fall für alle, die das Programm unterstützen, das hilft auf jeden Fall sehr.
So, dann kommen wir mal zu Deutschland. Pavel.
Ja, Deutschland.
Deutschland. Denken wir an Deutschland am Nachmittag. Dann äh ja kann man so ein komisches Gefühl entwickeln und jetzt ist grade mal wieder so richtig habe ich so den Eindruck.
Wir haben auch Fragen von euch bekommen. Ich hätte auf Twitter gestern nochmal rumgefragt und äh die haben wir ja auch alle aufgeschrieben,
Viele davon und versuchen die auch in irgendeiner Form zu beantworten.
Ich würde meinen, wir fangen einfach mal ganz klassisch an und schauen einfach mal auf die Infektionslage in Deutschland, so wie sie das RKI regelmäßig berichtet und wie du
sie ja auch nach wie vor immer wieder abrufst und einpflegst und auswertest.
Auf deiner Tabelle Risikotabelle Punkt DE. Da könnt ihr äh äh jemanden selber nachschlagen, wenn ihr's mal ganz genau wissen wollt.
Aus.
Ja, wobei ich äh tatsächlich auch in den letzten Wochen ähm ja nicht jeden Tag,
hatte. Werde das jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder etwas häufiger äh tun
aber äh ja, wie's aussieht? Ich meine, äh wir sind halt voll in einer vierten Welle jetzt drin mit einer Inzidenz äh von hundertfünfundsechzig
Neuinfizierten pro hunderttausend in den letzten sieben Tagen gemeldet und kommen halt auf rechnerisch auf einen R-Wert von
1,15. So, das heißt, es gibt halt weiter,
oben und wir haben jetzt noch nicht ganz den Gipfel, der.
Ähm dritten Welle erreicht, aber das wird so in den nächsten Tagen passieren. So jedenfalls, was jetzt die reinen,
Inzidenzen angeht.
Da bist du dir sicher.
Ja, das sieht äh gerade äh ganz so aus. Allerdings,
ist halt jetzt Inzidenz nicht mehr gleich Inzidenz seit äh viele Leute geimpft sind. Das heißt.
Ähm es gibt halt.
Eher weniger ja äh Tote und äh symptomatische Erkrankungen.
Sodass äh ja man eigentlich,
für die Frage, wie schlimm es jetzt eigentlich eine bestimmte Inzidenz eher hm einen Faktor,
setzen muss. Also 165 in der aktuellen Welle ist jetzt nicht so schlimm wie,
die rund 1700 in der zweiten Welle, die wir hatten, als als Gipfel so. Man muss also eigentlich, wenn man,
jetzt zum Beispiel zum Normieren heranzieht, wie viele Menschen denn äh in Folge jetzt der Infektion sterben.
Konnte man bisher in den letzten Monaten einen Faktor von drei,
ungefähr ansetzen, das heißt man könnte sozusagen die Inzidenz,
ungefähr durch drei teilen, um sie dann mit der,
Ja, mit der zweiten Welle.
Zu vergleichen, äh wobei Deutschland weit natürlich auch es immer drauf ankommt, wie die sich in den in den Altersgruppen verteilen.
Aber dieser Anstieg, den wir jetzt gesehen haben, hat halt auch in allen
Altersgruppen stattgefunden. Da war jetzt nicht irgendwie eine dabei, wo man jetzt sagen könnte, okay, die das äh äh war jetzt halt am heftigsten und insbesondere, was auch noch anders ist, ist das doch
ja die Infektion,
Quoten äh bei den Älteren, also die Inzidenzen äh bei den Älteren äh doch,
deutlich geringer sind als das in den äh letzten Wellen, so der der Fall äh war oder speziell in der zweiten Welle der Fall war. In der dritten haben wir dann schon,
in den höheren Altersgruppen äh in Effekt von Impfung gesehen. So, das kann man vielleicht auch noch konstatieren. Was
aber auch noch jetzt dazu kommt, ist ähm weil die Zahl der Tests jetzt
eher moderat wieder wieder angestiegen ist, haben wir wahrscheinlich auch wieder eine eine größere Dunkelziffer äh im Moment, die man,
wahrscheinlich obendrauf rechnen muss.
Aber ähm das entscheidende Kriterium äh was jetzt die Politik auch äh ins Spiel gebracht hat, ist die Überlastung des Gesundheitssystems.
Und da sieht es so aus, also sieht es ein bisschen unübersichtlich aus so. Auf der einen Seite gehen die Zahlen hoch ähm,
auch bei jetzt den Hospitalisierungen und die Intensivstationen füllen sich in einigen Gegenden
auch äh mittlerweile ja in in beängstigendem Maße. Auf der anderen Seite gibt's diese seltsame
Anomalie,
dass ja offensichtlich massiv intensiv Betten entweder weggefallen sind oder dann eben jetzt mit anderen Patienten,
belegt sind, die ja auf die lange Bank geschoben.
Wurden während der vorherigen Wellen plus äh ja es sieht einfach auch so aus, dass viele Leute entweder die
die viele Leute, die im Gesundheitswesen arbeiten, entweder Überstunden,
oder krank sind oder sich äh einfach verabschiedet haben aus aus dieser Arbeit. Insofern
ist die Situation an den Kliniken grade etwas.
Unübersichtlich äh und äh ja zumindest nicht entspannend äh gerade.
Das ja gestern mal angeschaut und
veröffentlichten Zahlen sind irgendwie ein bisschen äh unbefriedigend in ihrer Wahrreichung. Ne, also es gibt halt ähm zum Beispiel eine Kurve, wie viele Betten sind denn verfügbar?
Das ist äh eine Zahl, die halt äh durch alle Wellen immer nach unten gedrückt wurde.
Als die Wellen dann zu Ende waren, auch nach einigen Wochen sind die zwar,
langsam ein bisschen hochgegangen, aber sind doch erheblich unter dem Niveau, was jeweils vorher geherrscht hat, äh geblieben und bewegen sich irgendwie aufm,
sehr niedrigen Level. Dazu gibt's dann auch noch eine Angabe, wie viel Prozent denn,
diese Intensivbetten auch jetzt konkret mit Coronapatienten ausgelastet sind und wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere, sind wir derzeit irgendwo so bei elf, zwölf Prozent.
Klingt ja erstmal nach relativ wenig nur wenn eben aus anderen Gründen,
nicht benannt werden. Ja, also zumindest in dieser veröffentlicht wird so jetzt nicht konkret draus hervorgeht, dann fragt man sich natürlich so okay, ja was für eine Art sonstiges Geschehen,
trägt ihn dazu bei, ja? Ah, so sind das irgendwie vermehrte Operationen, die durchgeführt werden. Sind das ähm.
Andere Infektionskrankheiten, die jetzt unter Umständen auch wieder anziehen. Also was ist jetzt genau eigentlich der Grund dafür?
Die Verteilung so ist wie sie ist und wie hat sie sich eben relativ zu der Verfügbarkeit der Betten entwickelt und auch über diese Personalsituation kann man jetzt nur,
bisschen mutmaßen.
Zumindest geht es aus diesen Zahlen nicht jetzt klar hervor, ähm ob das jetzt primär der Grund war für irgendeinen Rückgang. Also ist freie Betten jetzt nur.
Ein Ergebnis von,
Personalverlust und und und Krankmeldungen. Ja, also äh oder inwiefern äh hängt das überhaupt mit irgendwelchen Sachen zusammen. Also das ist mir auch selber noch ein bisschen unklar. Ich werde so richtig nicht schlau daraus.
Ja
Und es gab zwischendurch wurde dann auch der Verdacht geäußert, dass einige,
in der Pandemie irgendwie Betten, Zahlen, also,
Zahlen von freien Betten gemeldet,
äh die in Wirklichkeit gar nicht hätten in Betrieb genommen werden können, weil das Personal gar nicht dafür da war, aber man irgendwie das Geld dafür mitgenommen hat, äh,
was dann äh irgendwie für die Bereitstellung wohl wohl bezahlt wurde.
In welchem Umfang das jetzt eine Rolle spielt, das kann ich jetzt auch nicht qualifiziert beantworten, aber ich würde jetzt auch nicht bezweifeln, dass es da äh
das ist das sicherlich hier und da gegeben hat, dass halt ein äh Mehrbetten gemeldet wurden, als tatsächlich jetzt
äh ja hätten belegt werden können, aber ob das ob das jetzt Einzelfälle waren oder
äh ein größeres Ausmaß hatte, das wage ich jetzt nicht äh zu beurteilen.
Ja gut, auf jeden Fall hat's nicht dazu beigetragen, dass diese Zahlen hochgehen, sondern sie bleiben einfach niedrig und man hat so auch das Gefühl, dass dieser Intensivbereich sich so richtig nicht erholt bekommt. Also das ist einfach,
ein Bereich ist, der extrem unter Druck ist. Und genau das ist jetzt die Situation,
vor dem Winter. Wir sind jetzt eigentlich schon mitten im Herbst, zumindest regnet's hier äh gerade entsprechend. Und wir wissen alle, dass das äh ein Problem ist. Die Infektionszahlen,
gehen halt unter anderem auch deswegen hoch. Ja und dann haben wir den Salat, weil jetzt äh haben wir auch noch diese spezifische Situation, dass durch die,
stärkeren Virusvarianten, Delta und die ganzen Sub-Varianten, die sich da auch noch entwickeln, aber im Wesentlichen geht's ja eigentlich immer noch um Delta.
Das haben wir ja schon auch oft erzählt und sollte eigentlich auch mittlerweile bekannt sein, dass eben diese Variante des Virus keinen Vergleich darstellt zu dem Virus, mit dem wir es noch vor einem Jahr äh zu tun hatten.
Durch diese höhere Übertragbarkeit, diese höhere Infizierbarkeit dieser Variante betrifft es halt jetzt eben auch jüngere Leute.
Die vielleicht vorher noch so ein bisschen dieses Glück gehabt haben, dass die ähm alten Varianten,
einfach nicht stark genug waren, äh um wirklich sich auch gegen gesündere Leute durchzusetzen und das ist halt jetzt immer weniger der Fall. Das heißt, trotz Impfung, die Leute, die ungeimpft sind und wir haben ja noch genug, da kommen wir sicherlich noch zu.
Laufen dem jetzt auch Gefahr vermehrt ähm krank zu werden und wenn die Leute dann auf die Intensivstationen kommen,
auch eine andere Belegungsdynamik als vor einem Jahr. Den waren's halt da noch eben die Alten und Schwachen.
Die dann eben.
Leider auch oft äh relativ schnell verstorben sind, hat man's jetzt mit mehr Gesundheitskampf auch den Intensivstationen zu tun und die Leute bleiben dann einfach auch sehr viel länger. Ja, die überleben es vielleicht am Ende.
Man jetzt nicht, keine Ahnung, also auf jeden Fall äh ist der Kampf länger und das bedeutet dann wiederum auch, dass die Belegung der Intensivbetten eben auch entsprechend höher ist. Das heißt, äh,
haben wir irgendwie die halbe Zahl, aber dann haben bleiben die Leute dreimal so lange und dann äh steigt der Druck eben auch noch weiter.
Das liegen zumindest auch Zahlen aus dem Ausland äh äh nahe, dass dass das äh äh definitiv stattgefunden hat und einen Effekt war. Ähm.
Was.
Uns bisher noch so ein bisschen ausgeblieben ist im Gegensatz zu den USA ist, dass bei uns jetzt nicht so riesige Mengen an Kindern sterben.
Ja. Äh in den in den USA ist wohl von, ich weiß nicht, über hundert,
Kindern die Rede so durch Covid.
In den letzten weiß ich nicht Monaten oder so und äh ja bei uns sind es nach wie vor eher Einzelfälle. So würde ich sagen, eine Handvoll.
Die jetzt in den letzten Monaten also 5 bis zehn irgendwo die äh in der Statistik auftauchen jetzt als als Covid Opfer und die USA hat jetzt nicht zehnmal so viele Leute.
Ja, also da ist insofern ist da auch noch irgendwas äh unklar. Sagen oder oder,
lässt sich mir gerade nicht ist äh ja, habe ich jetzt erst mal,
keine unmittelbare Erklärung dafür, warum in anderen Teilen der Welt scheinbar äh deutlich mehr Kinder an an covid sterben.
Trotzdem sind Kinder äh betroffen und zwar gar nicht mal unmittelbar nur durch Corona, sondern eben jetzt auch durch andere Viren. Ähm,
Unter anderem treibt gerade dieser RSV Virus der respiratorische Virus, wie er so schön heißt, ähm die Runde. Ähm,
Und das hat eben sehr viel auch damit zu tun, dass wir eben letztes Jahr diese ganzen Maßnahmen hatten und jetzt eben so viel Schutz war und
sich dann eben entsprechende Erreger nicht so gleichförmig wie sie das eben sonst tun durch die Gesellschaft und dann eben auch durch die äh Kinder so äh hindurch.
Weiter äh verbreitet und nach dieser langen Pause
schlägt es jetzt äh entsprechend doppelt zu und das ähm,
ein ziemliches Problem zu sein und vor allem in Kinderkrankenhäusern,
geht halt auch einfach die Zahl der Betten zurück, also auch die sind jetzt mit so einem,
Ansturm hm konfrontiert, der nicht so ohne weiteres wegzustecken ist.
Ja. Nein. Ein äh ich sage mal.
Rätsel hier auch grade, was ich mir auch noch nicht ganz erklären kann, ob das eine statistische Anomalie ist äh oder ähm ja es.
Der Fall, dass gerade in der Altersgruppe so von null bis vier ähäh eine vergleichsweise niedrige Inzidenz herrscht. So.
Ähm während des halt bei ähm.
Ja, bei den 5 bis 14-jährigen äh halt extrem abgeht. So ähm.
Also wenn man sich das das hier mal anguckt ähm.
Haben wir jetzt in der Altersgruppe fünf bis vierzehn haben wir jetzt eine Inzidenz von dreihundertdreizehn, ja.
Während wir in der Altersgruppe hm.
Null bis vier, grade mal bei neunzig sind.
So und 90 ist auch ungefähr das ähm also bei bei jetzt den.
Bei achtzig plus liegen wir jetzt bei hundertacht und äh bei 60 bis 9undsiebzig
Alter liegen wir jetzt bei 90. Also das sind sozusagen die die ganz jungen und die ganz Alten liegen jetzt bei den Inzidenzen auf den unteren drei Plätzen. Während,
äh wie gesagt, ist vor allem bei den 5 bis 14-jährigen ähäh ziemlich heftig abgeht
und auch bei den ja 15 bis 34-jährigen wir mit äh einer Inzidenz von 2hundert noch gut dabei sind.
Und die 35 bis 59-Jährigen liegen halt so im Mittelfeld sind mit 162 sozusagen liegen die im im im Durchschnitt. So.
Äh verteilt sich das grade äh auf auf das Alter und äh interessanterweise eben die Null- bis Vierjährigen, die halt alle gar nicht geimpft sind. Äh warum die hier mit äh so einer niedrigen Inzidenz
auftauchen. Ähm wobei man aber auch wiederum feststellen muss, dass in der zweiten Welle äh war's halt.
Ähnlich einmal in der zweiten Welle, haben irgendwie die.
Die ganz Kleinen auch nicht so richtig mitgemacht. Ja,
Äh vielleicht hat ja die Delta-Variante irgendwie bevorzugt,
die äh über Fünfjährige und mag irgendwie die ganz Kleinen noch nicht so oder die,
Kleinen kommen mit Delta irgendwie besser. Klar, aber auf der anderen Seite,
grade wiederum die dritte Welle äh wo äh,
äh die dann äh ja die Null- bis Vierjährigen äh so massiv beteiligt waren oder stärker beteiligt waren zumindest als in allen anderen
äh wählen. Also mit den ganz Kleinen geht geht,
irgendwie Seltsames vor oder äh man testet sie einfach nicht, weil es hat sich einfach gesagt, okay, was soll's, äh da läuft halt jetzt die Nase und bevor dann in Quarantäne müssen und wir sind ja schließlich
geimpft und äh keine Ahnung. Äh wie sieht denn das aus eigentlich an den Schulen im Moment? Wird da regelmäßig getestet gerade?
Also ist ein bisschen schwierig aus meiner Perspektive für alle Schulen zu reden. Ich kenne bestenfalls die Situation in Berlin.
Und ähm aus meiner äh persönlichen Perspektive äh ist es eher so, es wäre also die, die geimpft sind, die müssen sich nicht mehr regelmäßig testen lassen, aber es
sonst zwo, zwei oder dreimal die Woche äh Schnelltest vorm Unterricht. Und natürlich Masken.
Das ist so die Situation.
Dadurch jetzt abgefangen wird, äh ist schwer zu sagen, aber ein gewisses Testregime ist da auf jeden Fall noch. Gibt natürlich auch Länder wie NRW, die.
Eh schon wieder voll auf Freedom Day Modus umgeschaltet haben und irgendwie die Maskenpflicht in Schulen äh abgeschafft haben zur Unzeit, also es ist einfach wirklich wieder völlig.
Völlig absurd und irrationale
Handlungsanweisungen entgegen den den Trends und Voraussagen und äh wie ich finde eben auch entgegen der Notwendigkeiten.
Macht mal wieder so den Eindruck, als wenn jetzt hier wieder äh unsere Lockerungsverheißung in den Raum geworfen, genau zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo man sie eigentlich überhaupt nicht machen sollte.
Schon mal im Februar.
Ja ja. Ich meine, NRW steht jetzt nicht äh den Zahlen nach jetzt nicht so superschlimm
äh äh da oder äh ja auch ist zwar auch nicht toll, aber bewegt sich da eher im im unteren Drittel,
gerade, was so die Inzidenzen betrifft, aber was so die, ja, Fünf- bis 14-jährigen äh angeht.
Haben sie da äh ganz sind sie da auf ganz schöne Piks gekommen, aber jetzt auch nicht,
nicht gerade aktuell exorbitant höher, sondern folgen eigentlich auch,
gerade dem aktuellen oder dem dem normalen Trend äh in Deutschland trennt, sage ich mal.
Ja, der Trend ist nicht gut, also das ist ähm stark Bundesland abhängig und derzeit ist, glaube ich, das Infektionsgeschehen am stärksten in Sachsen und in in in Bayern, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Thüringen ist vorne gerade wieder, äh also.
Ähm was jetzt, wenn man den den also wenn man den R-Wert mit ein äh bezieht, also in der in der,
Liste und äh ja, auch aber auch bei den absoluten Inzidenzen. Grade ja Thüringen dreihundertfünfundsiebzig ähm.
Und Sachsen 369.
Die gehen also gut mit Bayern 258 so alles nach publizierten Fällen jetzt ähm.
Ja, also in Sachsen laufen auf jeden Fall die Krankenhäuser ganz ordentlich vor und hier äh gibt's auch so die Einschätzung, dass so in zwei, drei Wochen ähm.
Eine vollständige Überlastung des Gesundheitssystems Aussicht steht, wenn sich das nicht noch ändert.
Abschließend auf die hm Positiv Quote mein Freund. Also letztlich.
Äh Rechnung, wie viel Tests machen wir denn eigentlich? Wie viel sind denn davon positiv, dass die Positivquote und das ist ja hier auch so ein wiederkehrendes Memen in dieser Sendung.
Dass äh es sich immer wieder zeigt eigentlich, dass diese Positiv-Quote, die dem Infektionsgeschehen in gewisser Hinsicht immer etwas hinterherhängt,
trotzdem eine ganz gute Aussagen machen lässt darüber, wie eigentlich so der Gesamttrend nun tatsächlich ist. Sprich verbessert sich die Situation.
Geht die Positivquote auch runter, weil,
all die Leute, die getestet werden, nur sehr wenige davon werden, positiv getestet und das zeigt dann eben so, okay, alles klar. Nierige Positivquote, jetzt haben wir auch wirklich so einen Punkt erreicht und unter fünf Prozent kann man eben diesen Wert eben auch,
ganz gut glauben, schenken, wenn das Infektionsgeschehen dann wieder anzieht, dann dauert's eine Weile, bis äh diese Quote dann auch nachläuft, aber sie zeichnet eben im Nachgang
immer sehr schön ab wie's war. Es ist so so ein bisschen die Wahrheit der Vergangenheit.
Ja, wir sind ja und aktuell sind wir halt jetzt wieder bei fast elf Prozent, also sie hat wieder einen zehn Komma neun fünf,
das Ding hat jetzt halt äh wieder einen Riesensprung,
oben äh gemacht und äh ja, wir nähern uns auch bei der positiven Quote jetzt äh der.
Dem Peak der letzten Welle, der dann halt bei zwölf Komma vier vier,
lag und ähm.
Ja äh das bestätigt also, dass äh ja,
zumindest die Infektion des Virus ist da, es ist präsent, es es verbreitet sich, es
nutzt die Rechenleistung unseres Körpers um sich selbst zu optimieren und weiter zu verbreiten. Ähm
und äh ja, also live and kicking so. Ähm nicht so schön.
Ja
In Zahlen haben wir also gehabt, achthundertfünfundneunzigtausend achthundertsechsundneunzigtausend Tests, die Zahlen, die Testzahlen ähm.
Tschau. So ein bisschen würde ich sagen, ne, so.
Irgendwie vor ein paar Wochen mal bei einer Million. Ging ja ein bisschen runter, jetzt wieder ein bisschen äh ganz kleines wenig ein bisschen hoch. Ja.
Aber ja positiv Quote spricht eine deutliche Sprache. Zehn Komma neun fünf heißt, dass wir mal wieder so ein bisschen den Zugriff auf das Infektionsgeschehen eigentlich verloren haben und das bestärkt natürlich auch die Annahme.
Ähm dass die Zahlen weiter steigen werden.
Wir eigentlich grade noch wieder kein klares Bild haben und generell davon ausgegangen werden muss, dass es jetzt noch weiter steigt und das tut's halt im Herbst.
Das Wetter wird uns nicht weiterhelfen und ja und.
Freedom, denn äh viele hier schon wieder in Anspruch nehmen mit Veranstaltungen, die hier stattfinden, Veranstaltungen, die größere Teilnehmerzahlen haben,
Veranstaltung, Barbetriebe äh et cetera, die stattfinden und die, ja, werden wir auch noch drüber reden.
Relativ lässig auch äh Tests auf Impfung vornehmen.
Ganze Geschrei um 2G und 3G-Varianten. Das trägt alles jetzt nicht unbedingt dazu bei, dass äh das Gesamtgeschehen,
besser wird und das halt in der Situation, wo eben eine ganz wichtige Altersgruppe immer noch nicht geimpft werden kann, nämlich die fünf bis 12-jährigen. Die kommen zwar demnächst dran.
Aber derzeit ist es eben noch nicht so.
Dann schauen wir doch vielleicht mal ganz kurz äh auch ins Ausland, inwiefern wir da jetzt eigentlich ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal haben oder mit der Welle mit äh mit den allgemeinen Wellen so mitschwimmen.
Weil gut Blick auf Deutschland ist immer das, was uns am meisten interessiert, aber gibt ja auch noch andere Länder.
Und ähm ja, da sitzt teilweise noch wilder aus.
Ja. Also ähm.
Vielleicht mal nur auf unsere Nachbarländer äh schauen. Ja, also alles, was so direkt an uns angrenzt. Da kann man irgendwie sehen, na ja, ähm.
Ja immer rum.
Da gibt's noch andere Pappenheimer. Da sind wir eher so im so im Mittelfeld, ne. Also in der Schweiz, in Polen, Luxemburg, Frankreich ist das Infektionsgeschehen niedriger äh stärker ist es in Dänemark.
Noch schlimmer in Niederlanden, Tschechien geht mal wieder hoch, das wievielte Welle haben die jetzt eigentlich mittlerweile? Für die zwanzigste. Ähm Österreich ist auch schon wieder wild unterwegs und ähm.
Alter Bekannter Belgien.
Ja, Österreich und Tschechien gehen ganz gut ab. Äh so. Äh tatsächlich ja äh die liegen jetzt so in den,
vier 500er bei vier 5hunderter Inzidenzen so ja,
ist irgendwie auch die ganze Zeit dabei, aber macht eher so eine Säge Sägezahnbewegung äh jetzt äh interessanterweise
Also da geht's irgendwie immer ein bisschen rauf und ein bisschen runter und wieder ein bisschen rauf und wieder runter. Und aktuell geht's da gerade wieder runter.
Ja ähm.
Interessantestes Beispiel ist vielleicht Israel so äh oder ja, du wolltest erstmal die Nachbarländer, aber die Nachbarländer.
Israel gehen, Nachbarländer beziehungsweise überhaupt Europa und ähm,
drüber diskutieren, ob Israel jetzt noch in Europa liegt oder nicht. Auf jeden Fall werden wir jetzt mal den EU- und äh unmittelbare Anrainer nimmt,
fällt auf, dass ein extrem starkes Infektionsgeschehen generell im Osten Europas zu sehen ist. Also derzeit sind die baldischen Länder ziemlich stark betroffen. Ich glaube, in ähm Litauen war's glaube ich.
Sind auch schon wieder äh im Lockdown. So krass ist es da ähm abgegangen.
Aber auch keine guten Nachrichten gibt's von Bulgarien und schon gar nicht von Rumänien, die auch alle mit einem extrem niedrigen Impfquoten zu kämpfen haben.
Entsprechend dann halt auch durch die ganze Fake News verunsicherte Bevölkerung, die sich nicht impfen lassen will.
Auch in Russland und ja, das ähm.
Da auch massiv Menschenleben. Also gerade in Rumänien, da ist das.
Krankenhaussystem definitiv schon lange extrem überlastet,
Ja und das äh das sieht gar nicht gut aus für die. Also sicherlich wird's immer wieder so Wellen geben, wo das Infektionsgeschehen eingedämmt werden kann, aber.
Wir werden uns hier noch 50 Mal wiederholen.
Unserer Auffassung nach ist die Sache halt total klar. Das Einzige, was jetzt hier irgendwie helfen könnte, sind hohe Impfquoten. Die erreichen wir schon in Deutschland nicht in dem äh Maße, aber in anderen Ländern ist halt teilweise äh noch schlimmer,
was halt jetzt auch so ein bisschen dann langsam mit dazukommt, ist das natürlich dann auch die Impfung oder die Zweitimpfung, die schon verabreicht worden sind, jetzt nach einigen Monaten natürlich auch in zunehmendem Maße,
abklingen. Das ist dann zwar meistens für die Leute, die geimpft sind und,
sich ähm infizieren, dann nicht so schlimm, weil halt schwere Fälle nach wie vor verhältnismäßig zuverlässig durch den Impfstoff abgemildert werden.
Aber die Infektionsausbreitung, die wird dadurch eben nicht nennenswert gestoppt. Also man weiß zwar, dass Leute, die geimpft sind, Prinzip.
Ein, zwei Tage früher.
Viruslast runtergeht oder vielleicht auch nie so hoch ansteigt oder vielleicht auch etwas später einsetzt, aber es gibt definitiv auch eine infektiöse Phase.
Und ähm das äh ist natürlich doof und ähm.
Daher müsste eben die ganze Impfquote sehr viel höher sein. Aber wenn man eben viele Ungeimpfte noch hat, die es dann auch immer wieder erwischt, dann,
da wo wir vor einem Jahr.
Ja Plus Plus, was wir, worauf ich ja auch schon immer hingewiesen habe, noch bevor äh.
Ja äh jetzt im großen Maßstab äh jetzt geimpft wurde, waren halt die Studien äh nach denen,
man, je älter die Menschen waren, äh umso weniger äh auch äh Antikörper äh äh.
Konnten, konnte man nachweisen, nach der Impfung und so bei einem Drittel
eigentlich der über 80-jährigen äh konnte man in dem äh in der in der Studie keine Antikörpernachweisen auch nach der zweiten Impfung, was jetzt nicht
Heißt, dass diese Menschen jetzt überhaupt gar keinen ähm.
Schutz äh durch durch die Impfung haben, aber wir können schon davon ausgehen, dass Größen ordnungsmäßig äh äh schon vielleicht zehn, zwanzig
Prozent ungefähr der über 80-jährigen so dann eben kein
ausreichenden äh Schutz haben oder ja möglicherweise überhaupt gar keinen äh Schutz, also wo die Impfung dann äh so gut wie gar nicht wirkt oder oder nur sehr unzureichend äh äh wirkt so.
Und ähm das ist natürlich jetzt auch ein Problem äh in Verbindung damit, dass die die Ersten waren, die geimpft worden sind und
dass dort jetzt auch sagen dort wo vielleicht anfänglich dann noch ein ganz guter Schutz da war er mittlerweile auch äh noch nachgelassen hat. Ähm so
Ähm und.
Das äh sind dann äh natürlich auch nach wie vor das das Gros der schweren Fälle und der der Todesfälle. Also grundsätzlich hat sich daran jetzt nichts geändert. Dass halt auch ältere Menschen
ja 'ne um Größenordnung höhere Sterbewahrscheinlichkeit haben.
Ja.
Wie gesagt sind da die Inzidenzen noch äh mit am niedrigsten äh in den Altersgruppen, aber eben äh.
Kommt trotzdem dann was zusammen.
Kurz nochmal auf die Impfsituation in Deutschland äh eingehen, bevor wir vielleicht nochmal auf den Sonderfall Israel äh schauen.
Es gibt nicht viel Gutes zu berichten. Die Impfzahlen sind niedrig, also erschreckend niedrig.
Und ähm wir sind jetzt grade mal bei na ja knapp 67 Prozent vollständig geimpfter Personen, also die mindestens zwei Impfungen bekommen haben.
Äh nähert sich das sozusagen auch dieser Erstimpf kurve in zunehmendem Maße an, weil einfach auch viele Leute einfach gar nicht mehr.
Sich frisch impfen lassen. Also man merkt einfach, dass das Impfpotential Deutschlands ähm scheint langsam so ein bisschen äh erreicht zu sein, also zumindest das Potenzial unter den aktuellen Bedingungen.
In der Art und Weise, wie mit der Impfung umgegangen wird und.
Es ist auch wirklich total äh frustrierend, ne? Ich meine, wir hatten dann am Anfang diese relativ.
Schnell aufgezogenen Impfzentren, die auch gut funktioniert haben, die dann wirklich in großen Mengen Leute durchgeimpft bekommen haben.
Gab's diese Schreierei bei den Hausärzten so, ja und überhaupt und Impfung, das machen wir doch eigentlich und wir müssen jetzt hier auch mitmachen und nur, wenn die Hausärzte dabei sind, dann kann das überhaupt was werden und wir sind ja so viele,
so und so viel tausende von Praxen und wenn wir das machen, dann geht das irgendwie rucki zucki mal heute auch bei der Grippeimpfung auch.
Dann hat das irgendwie auch eine Weile funktioniert, dann war das äh tatsächlich so eine Hälfte Hälfte Geschichte, aber diese Impfzentren die waren immer.
Wichtig und haben so oder so äh einen signifikanten Teil der Impfungen durchgeführt. So, dann gingen die Zahlen relativ gut hoch.
Und dann haben sich halt alle so die Zahlen und die Entwicklungen angeschaut und gesagt, naja, also wenn das so weitergeht, so, dann ist ja bald vorbei.
Hier diese Impfzentren ist ja wohl voll teuer. Weil die Impfzentren werden halt von den Ländern bezahlt. So und die sehen natürlich dann auch erstmal so ein bisschen die Kosten. Und relativ früh wurde klar,
es gibt einen extremen Druck, diese Impfzentren zu schließen. Das war dann in Berlin so, in Sachsen, so, in vielen anderen Ställen auch so, dass er halt einfach gesagt wurde, ja, die machen wir dann halt irgendwann zu weit, brauchen wir ja dann nicht mehr.
Schon von Anfang an gefragt habe so äh,
Erstens, wo er wisst ihr das, zweitens seid ihr euch sicher, dass das so eine gute Idee ist. Und jetzt haben wir zum Beispiel hier in äh Berlin die Situation, dass wir von glaube ich zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt gab's da mal fünf oder sechs Impfzentren, die wir äh offen hatten.
Gibt's nur noch zwei.
Und ähm die laufen, bei dem einen bin ich mir jetzt gerade gar nicht so sicher, aber die Verträge fürs andere laufen halt jetzt bis Ende Januar.
Und das ist halt das Impfzentrum in Tegel, was im Prinzip, wo im Prinzip sehr viele hingegangen sind, die vorher in dieser Arena waren und die Arena war wiederum.
Östlichste Impfzentrum. Falls jetzt sind beide Impfzentren sind irgendwie im Westen an einer Messer und einen so ein bisschen so im Nordwesten. Der ganze Osten hat überhaupt gar kein Impfzentrum, lauft er. Kann man natürlich sagen, na ja, aber die Hausärzte, nur die Hausärzte.
Richtig am kotzen, weil.
Kommt auch noch Grippeimpfung dazu, die sind auch gestresst und überfordert mit diesem ganzen Impfaufkommen. Diese ganze Organisation und das Melden und so weiter äh,
Praxen sind einfach nicht in der Lage in diesen Mengen Leute da durchzuschicken. Mögen zwar viele Praxen sein, aber wir haben ja auch gesehen,
Praxen, die impfen gar nicht. Es gibt Praxen, die impfen nur sehr
widerwillig und immer nur streng nach Skiko und machen irgendwie Ärger und hat sich eine relativ hohes Frustpotential auch aufgebaut, so auf beiden Seiten würde ich sagen, sowohl bei den Ärzten durch die Überforderung.
Und vor allem auch die Überforderung im Vergleich zu ihrem normalen Betrieb, den sie dann teilweise durch diese Impfung auch nicht mehr so aufrecht erhalten konnten. Ne,
alles Personal und Zeit und Vorbereitung und was nicht alles. Und ähm bei den Impfzentren ist Frustration natürlich auch, weil.
Derzeit einfach so wenig los ist.
Natürlich auch eine Frustrationspotential dann eben bei Leuten, die Impfungen haben wollen, aber irgendwie Schwierigkeiten haben, irgendwelche Termine zu machen.
Information. Derzeit ist es relativ einfach, Termine zu machen. Man geht einfach zum Impfzentrum und wird geimpft. So, ja, also.
Klar, da muss man vielleicht mal ein bisschen fahren, aber derzeit ist es nun wirklich überhaupt gar kein Problem. Es gibt äh genug Impfstoff. Es gibt genug Möglichkeiten in Impfzentren. Nur es gibt halt auch einfach Regionen in Deutschland. Da gibt's einfach in einer nennenswerten Umgebung.
Keinerlei Impfzentrum. Es gibt einfach gar keine Möglichkeit mehr, weil die Länder eben gesagt haben, das ist uns einfach zu teuer.
Tja und jetzt haben wir den Salat, weil und das war, fand ich für mich, war das von Anfang an absehbar.
Dass wir äh auf eine dritte Impfung setzen müssen.
Ursprünglich war es ja so, dass wir davon ausgegangen sind, dass die Varianten des Virus sich so weit.
Weiterentwickeln, dass unter Umständen die Impfstoffe nicht mehr greifen. Das war ja so eine.
Annahme und sicherlich auch nicht komplett aus der äh aus dem Nichts gegriffen. Tatsächlich ist es so, dass die Impfstoffe, so wie sie von Anfang an designt wurden, auch wunderbar auch noch bei Delta greifen.
Ja, man kann es irgendwie streiten über die Wirksamkeit und so und zu viel Prozent, aber generell gab es bisher noch nicht diesen Drive mit. Wir müssen jetzt die Impfstoffe komplett nochmal in so eine 20 Version überführen.
Wobei sicherlich so eine zweinull Version, die irgendwie auch äh sozusagen besser äh äh Delta erkennt, wahrscheinlich auch nicht schlecht wäre.
Äh so und mit Sicherheit auch äh sich ja in der Entwicklung befindet. Ähm.
Aber wann wann da was kommt? Unklar. Hast du da irgendwie was.
Ja weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz genau, aber ich wollte ja erstmal drauf hinaus, warum es eigentlich von vornherein eigentlich eine eine gute Idee gewesen ist
Impfzentren auch langfristig in Betrieb zu halten, weil einfach eine Drittlimpfung, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, äh notwendig sein kann. Man dachte zwar anfangs wegen der anderen Varianten,
Jetzt ist es halt eben und das war genauso absehbar oder zumindest immer im Bereich des Möglichen, dass einfach diese Impfwirkung irgendwann auch.
Nachlässt, was ein ganz normaler Vorgang ist und genau das sehen wir jetzt und deswegen wird diese Booster Impfung, diese Drittlimpfung, jetzt wirklich wichtig und genau zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo sie wirklich wichtig ist.
Keine Impfzentren mehr und überforderte Ärzte und Herbst und Winter.
Und.
Noch so eine weitere, vielleicht etwas äh anekdotische äh Geschichte, aber ich ich denke, die ist schon ein Stück weit äh,
gemeiner Bar und zwar meine Tochter hat sich halt ihre äh Impfung dann auch in einem Impfzentrum äh besorgt, weil äh.
Das Ding ist, dass du als Jugendlicher oder viele Jugendliche einmal einen Kinderarzt so
Aber irgendwann so, wenn man dann älter wird und äh aber ansonsten
eher ja gesund ist äh oder äh dann halt einfach kein kein Arzt braucht, hat man halt auch keinen. Ja und äh das heißt gerade viele junge Leute so Anfang zwanzig
haben dann nicht nur die Hürde und sicherlich nicht nur Anfang 20 es gilt wahrscheinlich für alle.
Altersstufen, dass dass eine Menge Leute einfach gar keinen Hausarzt haben in dem Sinne, denn sie regelmäßig frequentieren so. Das heißt
die müssen dann nicht nur irgendwie bei ihrem Arzt dann durchkommen und äh dort dann in der Regel telefonisch einen Termin,
vereinbaren
Gut, viele Ärzte haben auch äh irgendwo kann man sich sicherlich auch Online-Termine buchen, aber aber allgemein Standard ist das jetzt nicht
unbedingt
Während ja bei so einem Impfzentrum kann man entweder auch äh online einen Termin machen oder wie gesagt oder sogar einfach hingehen ohne Termin. Und das ist natürlich, wenn man auch ähm langen Wert darauf
legt eine möglichst hohe Impfquote äh zu bekommen, äh ist natürlich der niederschwellige Zugang äh zu einer Impfung. Auf jeden Fall äh immer einen Faktor und ich glaube, ja
bei Jüngeren noch Leuten noch umso mehr.
Also was äh natürlich auch stimmt.
Ähm ist dieses Argument ja, man muss auch zu den Leuten hingehen, ne. Wir haben ja diesen Fall in Bremen, ne? Bremen ist ja äh das Bundesland, was wirklich mit Abstand die besten Ergebnisse hat. Ne und jetzt kann man ja.
Davon ausgehen, dass jetzt in Bremen irgendwie.
Die Leute nennenswert anders drauf sind. Ja, die haben auch ihre Problembezirke, die haben auch äh ganz normale Bürger, die lesen auch alle Facebook, also äh letzten Endes vielleicht einen etwas anderen Ausmaße, aber trotzdem
hast du auch in Bremen mit Sicherheit die selben Probleme, die du überall auch hast.
Trotzdem war Bremen immer vorne weg. Also am Anfang war das ja eher noch so ein bisschen Wettlauf mit wer wer kriegt eigentlich genug,
ne, wie verteilt sich das. Aber ab dem Moment, wo eben auch das nicht mehr das Problem war, ist dann äh Bremen einfach mal wunderbar davon gezogen und haben jetzt irgendwie,
eine Quote von fast achtzig Prozent vollständig geimpft, also 78,5ähErstimpfung 812. Damit führen sie einfach,
die Liste bei weitem äh an. Platz zwei ist dann irgendwie Saarland mit 73 so, dann kommen irgendwie Hamburg, Schleswig-Holstein, Nordrhein-Westfalen, Niedersachsen.
Berlin und äh ganz am Ende bin überrascht es noch Großsachsen. Davor Brandenburg davor,
Thüringen, da vor Sachsen-Anhalt, also der komplette Osten hängt hinterher. Der Abstand wirklich von Bremen achtundsiebzig ,fünf zu Sachsen 56,9.
Das sind einfach mal zwanzig Prozent. Das ist nicht irgendwie ein bisschen was.
Dann ist es einfach eine Katastrophe. So, aber wie haben sie's geschafft? Sie haben's halt dadurch gemacht, dass sie eben von vornherein mit mobilen Impfteams in,
Problembezirke gegangen sind den Leuten vor Ort das gemacht haben, dass sie es auch nachhaltig kommuniziert haben, einfach Angebote geschaffen haben äh ohne Ende.
Es auch immer noch tun, also da ist halt auch immer noch irgendwie weitere weiter hohes Impfgeschehen oder relativ hohes Impfgeschehen und wären wir jetzt alle so wie Bremen drauf.
Hätten wir in Deutschland diese 78,5 Prozent.
Dann hätten wir viele dieser Probleme nicht, weil er Unterschied zwischen 8undsiebzig und und und siebenundsechzig mag jetzt erstmal so als Zahl nicht so äh.
Einem ins Gesicht springen, aber das ist schon.
Eben einfach so, umso näher wir uns äh den niemals zu erreichenden hundert Prozent äh nähern. Jedes Prozent dazu macht die Situation irgendwie doppelt so gut.
Ja und und man sieht's halt an den Inzidenzen irgendwie. Bremen, Saarland äh sind jetzt äh um die siebzig,
80 ährum
werden halt ja Sachsen äh gerade wie gesagt über dreihundertfünfzig liegt. Das ist halt äh ja sehr wahrscheinlich, ich meine was was soll es sonst sein? Äh ich meine nur aber sehr wahrscheinlich
einfach auf die Unterschiede in der Impfquote.
Zurückzuführen. Nicht nicht nur, aber äh die wird äh mit Sicherheit ein großer Faktor sein. Ja und wenn wir wahrscheinlich werden wir überall die 80 Prozent hätten, dann könnten wir jetzt deutlich entspannter.
Sein ja.
Aber sind wir nicht.
Sind wir nicht.
Ja also.
Leute, echt. Jetzt kommt halt die Sache mit der Booster Impfung ins Spiel.
Dazu muss man auf jeden Fall auch noch mal ein paar Worte äh verlieren. Also, es ging ja ein bisschen hin und her und schon vor einigen Wochen hatten wir auch, glaube ich, schon drüber
Ist ja die Booster Impfung, zumindest mal für Leute im Pflegebereich, äh medizinischen Bereich und äh Leute ab siebzig, auch von der STEKO
Vornherein schon mal bejaht worden. Ich habe keine.
Konkreten Informationen jetzt dazu. Muss man äh sich noch mal so ein bisschen durch die Impfstatistiken ähm durchschauen, wie groß jetzt der Anteil der Älteren äh ist, die wirklich eine dritte Dosis bekommen haben.
Aber das dürfte äh relativ niedrig sein und jetzt äh.
Nach einiger Zeit hat sich dann äh die Bundesregierung auch durchgerungen, das mal so generell zu ermöglichen.
Und Stand jetzt ist halt einfach, also ich gucke grad mal hier die gesamte Auffrischungsimpfung äh bisher so 2,4 Millionen von irgendwie.
Potentiell sieben, acht Millionen, die es vielleicht jetzt schon bekommen könnten mit dem sechs Monat Abstand. Also die Aussage ist jetzt folgende. Jeder kann eine Aufschriftsimpfung bekommen.
Egal welches Alter der Abstand sollte sechs Monate betragen. Bisweilen habe ich gehört.
Wird auch ein Abstand von ein, zwei Wochen weniger auch mitgenommen. Also so.
Weiß ich sowas, da müsste man zur Not mal beim Impfzentrum nachfragen oder vielleicht auch bei den Ärzten, ja, wenn's irgendwie dreiundzwanzig, vierundzwanzig Wochen her ist, wird es wahrscheinlich auch schon funktionieren.
Geht man einfach hin, holt sich die dritte Impfung ab und gut ist. Denn und jetzt kommen wir vielleicht auch mal zu Israel kommen.
Israel hatte bis vor.
Einen Monat, eigentlich paar Wochen auch wieder mal eine sehr beunruhigende ähm vierte Welle.
Und die gingen richtig hoch, ja, also.
Ja, über tausend.
Genau, also extrem.
Allerdings klingt jetzt auch erstmal schlimm, war wahrscheinlich auch äh in gewisser Hinsicht schlimm, aber das war dann eben auch sehr schnell wieder im Griff. Warum? Weil einfach in.
Diese Boosterrimpfung ähm durchgedrückt wurde,
Soweit ich weiß, gibt's die ganzen Impfzentren noch, die Möglichkeiten. Es wurde einfach im großen Maße einfach weitergeimpft. Alle seit August dürfen halt eine Drittempfung bekommen in diesen sechs Monate Abstand hm haben.
Mittlerweile ist halt auch so, hat man, glaube ich, auch letztes Mal schon erwähnt, dass in Israel das auch so gilt, dass man jetzt gar nicht mehr als vollständig geimpft gilt, wenn man nicht die dritte Impfung hat.
Ja, so sie länger als sechs Monate her ist die Zweitimpfung.
Und deswegen sind halt auch alle angehalten das zu machen und dann haben sie wieder bemerkenswerte äh Impfzahlen an den Tag gelegt und siehe da, auf einmal gehen die Zahlen wieder enorm runter.
Ja, also keine große Überraschung in gewisser Hinsicht, aber genau das äh ist wieder mal passiert.
Ähm was man am Beispiel Israel dann auch ganz gut.
Sehen kann ist, äh wenn man äh so dazwischen den den den Fallkurven und äh der der Kurve der Todesfälle.
Ähm hin und her schaltet, dann sieht man, dass so zweite und,
also das die letzten beiden Wellen ähm ungefähr sagen wir gleich groß oder gleich hoch waren.
Was die Fallzahlen angeht, aber die Zahl der Todesfälle in der letzten äh großen Welle, äh obwohl die höher war
eher so in der Gegend Hälfte äh sich sich bewegt, sage ich mal, äh grob. Das heißt, ähm,
Das äh ja ähm die die Impfungen äh oder oder die Tatsache sagen,
dass die Leute geimpft waren äh in in Israel ähm,
ja die die Zahl der Toten halbiert hat mindestens. So äh ohne äh,
sagen wir, wenn wenn's jetzt die Impfung gar nicht gegeben hätte, auf welche Höhen
dann dass das möglicherweise an angestiegen wäre. Gut, man hätte dann auch mit Lockdown und anderem äh wäre man dem begegnet, aber ja
dass da kann man dann glaube ich schon grob die die Wirkung ähm der Impfung einfach mal abschätzen und vor dem Hintergrund dass ähm ja
dass das Virus sich potenziell auch noch verbessert,
haben könnte in der Zeit äh ein bisschen. Und äh ja wir es trotzdem halt besser geworden.
Man muss sich auch gar nicht auf Schätzungen äh verlassen. Es gab natürlich, wie das in Israel so üblich ist, auch eine wissenschaftliche Begleitung und eine klare Auswertung und daraus geht relativ klar hervor, dass diese dritte
Impfung, diese Booster Impfung nicht nur so eine kleine Verbesserung ist,
dass die dritte Impfung nochmal so richtig erst so richtig den Kick bringt und dass einfach der Schutz durch die dritte Impfung ungefähr zehnmal so stark ist.
Man ihn von der zweiten Impfung bekommen hat.
Mhm. Okay.
Das ist eine nennenswerte Zahl.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ja, ich hatte vorhin mit meinen Ausführungen jetzt sozusagen die Auswirkungen der Zweitimpfung äh äh.
So äh gemeint äh ja mit mit aber äh ja, das ist äh,
in der Tat, dass mich auch äh gehört. Ähm ich,
bin vor allen Dingen gespannt. Ich meine, wir haben haben ja beide sagen äh
Astra Silika und und Biontech äh bisher und äh ja, glaube der Plan ist ja jetzt auch dein Plan äh dann äh den Booster mit moderner zu machen.
Ja
Ja so Pokémon äh mäßig,
äh da fällt mir noch ein, weil das war mir halt auch nie äh so ganz klar, aber es hat sich auch gezeigt, dass moderner äh äh tatsächlich von allen Impfstoffen
bei Delta die wenigsten Durchbrüche
äh Impfdurchbrüche aufzuweisen hatte, also dass moderner sozusagen am besten wirksam war, was.
Aber vermutlich auch daran lag, dass äh moderner so mengenmäßig dreimal so hoch dosiert ist wie Biontech, ja. Das heißt äh die Wahrscheinlichkeit
äh ist, dass es jetzt nicht daran
lag der bessere Schutz. Das ist jetzt irgendwie einen strukturell wesentlich besserer Impfstoff ist, sondern dass man einfach dreimal so viel rein äh äh gehauen äh bekommen hat. Weshalb jetzt
auch ähm Sie wohl für die Booster Impfung ähm die Dosis reduziert haben. Wenn man.
Halbiert haben, um genau zu sein, ja.
Lässt. Ja, weil ich glaube anfangs hatten sie nämlich irgendwie nochmal eine volle Dosis, aber so Dritte, glaube, dritte Dosis moderner zeigte sich dann, war wohl ein bisschen heftig. Äh so,
äh es hat halt äh ziemlich viele Leute umgehauen und dann äh ja haben sie dann lieber gesagt, äh irgendwie okay Hälfte äh müsste eigentlich auch reichen. Ist es dann immer noch mehr als äh du bei Biontech äh äh kriegst
äh in einer vollen Dosis, aber äh ja so ist es.
So sieht's äh aus. Also das ähm ich kenne auch jemand ähm die hat äh tatsächlich auch diese Moderna Bussa volle Dosis bekommen und meinst du, das hätte sie schon ganz schön äh weggeschallert.
Alles immer noch nicht nachfühlen, weil ich eigentlich weder von der Dosis noch von viel gemerkt habe, aber da ist halt jeder auch irgendwie anders. Mal gucken, vielleicht ähm.
Merke ich ja bei moderner irgendwas. Dauert noch ein bisschen, bis ich da ligible bin, aber ähm ja muss auf jeden Fall kommen.
Ja, also ich habe bei beiden was gemerkt so
aber war jetzt auch nicht äh war ein halbwahr altes des Übliche irgendwie ein bisschen
an der Einstichstelle halt ein bisschen Schmerzen und ein bisschen ja Müdigkeit und ich stand dann auch
paar Tage hatte ich das Gefühl stand ich neben der Spur, habe ich auch schon gesagt, aber es war das war genau auch zu der Zeit, als wir irgendwie fünfunddreißig Grad hatten und ich mir da nicht sicher war, es ist jetzt die Hitze oder die Impfung, die mich grade so.
Macht.
Also die die ist jetzt noch so ein bisschen hinterher, aber es äh wird äh allgemein angenommen, dass es jetzt nicht mehr so lange dauert, bis dann auch mal die STIKO eine klare Aussage macht zu Booster für alle, weil die Datenlage wohl relativ überzeugend äh ist.
Ist zumindest das, was so überall äh gemauschelt äh äh wird, mit dass sich dem die STIKO jetzt auch nicht wieder wochenlang entziehen kann, sondern dass einfach diese Ergebnisse aus Israel und weiß nicht, wo es sonst noch äh Studien gegeben hat.
Eine relativ klare Sprache spricht, dass halt die Impfstoffe nach wie vor ja kein großes,
Problem darstellen für die allermeisten Leute und das eben speziell dieser Booster
es so richtig bringt und da ist halt Israel dann doch wirklich das allerbeste Beispiel.
Ja, weshalb wir mal wieder dann so eine Vorvorhersage zu äh wagen, die
zumindest vorhersagen dieser Art sind eigentlich,
fast alle eingetroffen, wenn nicht sogar sogar alle nämlich äh meine Vorhersage wäre, jetzt äh dass wir.
Auch dann ähm in absehbarer Zeit Dezember, Januar oder so wahrscheinlich auch aus der Politik äh,
sagen die Nachricht kriegen werden, dass äh zweifach Geimpfte äh dann nicht mehr als vollständig geimpft äh gelten, so wie in in in Israel, also
da gehe ich mal fest von aus, dass das früher oder später auch bei uns kommen wird.
Wahrscheinlich eher später als früher, aber es äh ich denke auch, dass werden wir äh äh auch noch sehen.
Wird so ein bisschen von der Inzidenzentwicklung abhängen, wie schnell das äh äh kommt. Äh aber bei offenbar ist, ich sage mal, die.
Des Boostern ist glaube ich dann
auch wahrscheinlich eher doch die die politisch und gesamt Gesellschaftlich am wenigsten schädliche Variante gegenüber jetzt weiß ich nicht Lockdowns oder wieder äh eine Ahnung äh
ähm Kneipen zumachen äh Veranstaltungen äh äh verbieten und was es da sonst noch alles gibt bis hin zum zum Lockdown unter Umständen.
So ein bisschen dieser Regierungspause, ist nicht klar, wer ist Gesundheitsministerium übernimmt, wenn äh sollte Karl Lauterbach wieder erwarten, doch Gesundheitsminister werden, dann denke ich mal, könnte sich da noch ein bisschen was bewegen, aber ich habe so den Eindruck, dazu wird es nicht äh kommen.
Aber nicht wirklich äh drin.
Vielleicht nochmal ein paar Klarstellungen, weil wir jetzt immer so ein bisschen von diesen mRNA Impfstoffen ausgegangen sind. Es gibt ja auch noch die Leute, die sich so eine Johnson und Johnson-Impfung geholt haben, die ja so ein bisschen versprochen hat. So ja hier ein,
und alles gut zeigt sich, dass Johnson und Johnson halt bei Delta noch mehr schwächelt.
Wer also eine Johnson und Johnson Impfung bekommen hat, kann sich auch schon nach 8undzwanzig Tagen.
Booster Impfung mit einem MRNA Impfstoff holen und sollte das auch unbedingt tun. Ja, das gilt dann quasi als Drittimpfung.
Glaube ich auch ähm im Zertifikat mit drei von drei vermerkt dann, um da nicht durcheinander zu kommen. Sprich äh da könnt ihr sofort zum Impfzentrum latschen, wenn ihr.
Kunden gewesen seid.
Ja und es spricht nichts dagegen. Es gibt keine Alterseinschränkung, es gilt einfach nur dieser Zeitabstand ne und den müsst ihr dann halt im Einzelnen nochmal äh schauen. Wie gesagt, ich würde euch immer zum Impfzentrum schicken, da geht es einfach schneller,
aber na ja. Impfstoff gibt's auf jeden Fall genug.
Impfstoff wird's auch geben für unsere Kinder. Denn der Impfstoff von Biontech ist jetzt.
Ist, glaube ich, ungefähr so eine Vierteldosis von dem, was äh Älteren geimpft wird, ist jetzt auch für die Altersgruppe von fünf bis elf zugelassen in den USA.
Und.
Gehe mal davon aus, dass das jetzt auch nicht mehr so lange dauern sollte in Deutschland, weil na ja, wir wissen ja, wenn's in den USA durch ist, dann ist das auch schon mal ein gutes Argument.
Ja, auf der anderen Seite, wenn man sich jetzt nur, wie gesagt, die Zahlen anguckt.
Äh scheint in den USA dort aufgrund der äh äh Vielzahl äh erkrankter und verstorbener Kinder
ähm die äh Dringlichkeit höher zu sein, sage ich mal, äh als als bei uns, ja.
Aber äh grundsätzlich ja äh wenn sich dort rausstellt äh wovon man ausgeht oder den Test hat es sich ja äh rausgestellt äh so äh dass das,
alles gut verträglich und unproblematisch,
ist äh dann ja, dürfte auch nichts dagegen sprechen, dass bei uns zuzulassen. Aber ähm,
wie gesagt bei uns äh so äh sind die Zahlen nicht so, nicht so schlimm bei den Kindern aus.
Mir nicht ganz äh nachvollziehbaren Gründen.
Ja, müssen wir nicht unbedingt abwarten, bis es so ist, finde ich, also.
Das kann was mit den dort verbreiteten Varianten zu tun haben oder auch äh wissen ja auch, dass
bestimmte genetische Dispositionen. Es es gibt für für schwerere Verläufe, vielleicht hat's damit was zu tun. Äh weiß ich nicht.
Äh aber das sind alles alles reine Spekulationen so, aber,
ist äh halt, dass in den USA irgendwie äh deutlich mehr Kinder äh betroffen sind als bei uns von schweren Verläufen und Tod.
Also ich kann's gar nicht ab äh warten bis dann mal das äh hier auch ermöglicht wird, weil das nimmt dann einfach auch den Druck aus den,
aus den Schulen raus, also wäre,
mal wieder davon auszugehen, ne, dass der dass der Schwobelanteil dann natürlich bei den Eltern auch genauso verteilt ist wie im Rest der Gesellschaft, sprich
dort werden wir dann vielleicht bestenfalls auf 70 Prozent kommen, aber lieber 70 Prozent der Kinder äh geimpft als äh als nicht, ne, beziehungsweise man muss jetzt auch nochmal korrigieren, ich hab's jetzt nicht äh im Detail nachgerechnet, ähm
diese 69,9 Prozent.
Ist ja nach wie vor eine Zahl Anteil der Bevölkerung. Das schließt also auch die ein,
eben bisher noch nicht geimpft werden konnten. Das muss man dabei äh immer wieder äh bedenken.
Äh ich habe jetzt hier meinen Rechner, meinen Rechner hier gerade mal am Start, tue ich das mal kurz äh ausrechnen könnte.
Weil leider so ein bisschen ähm also genau, wenn's hier mal neunundsechzig Komma neun Prozent.
Dann ja, gut, machst du einen Riesenunterschied auch nicht aus, das stelle ich gerade.
Vier Millionen, wir haben rund vier Millionen null bis Vierjährige äh so und nochmal.
Sieben Millionen fünf bis 14-jährige. Bislang ging's runter bis äh bis es geht runter, bis was im Moment? Zwölf war das?
Ja, heißt, da können wir noch mal zwei Millionen abziehen, also ja zehn also zehn Prozent ungefähr würde ich für dich schätzen, können sich noch nicht impfen lassen bisher. Äh so.
Also könnten wir maximal auf 90 Prozent äh kommen. Werden sozusagen 90 Prozent werden, wenn sich alle hätten impfen lassen.
Und äh ja.
Ich trage mal hier kurz die aktuelle Zahl ein, dann kann ich's dir auch genau sagen. Also wir haben jetzt vollständig geimpft ähm siebenundfünfzig acht.
So, genau. Das heißt, das sind 78,1 Prozent ungefähr, also ungefähr 78 Prozent.
Aller Menschen, die sich impfen lassen konnten, haben sich auch impfen lassen.
Ne, also wir haben quasi so zweiundzwanzig Prozent, also knapp ein Fünftel, sagt nein oder hat's noch nicht gemacht, warum auch immer. Ähm so und.
Wir könnten also auch auf einen entsprechenden Anteil bei den äh Kindern kommen.
Damit zusammen werden wir dann insgesamt äh ja vielleicht dann so Richtung 75 Prozent dann vielleicht von allen.
Ja, es reicht immer noch nicht. Wir bräuchten eigentlich 85, 995Prozent in der Gegend, um äh ja.
Gut, aber man kann durch das Boostern auf jeden Fall auch seinen Beitrag leisten,
das ist halt der Punkt, weil in dem Moment, wo man geboostert ist, wird man dann zumindest für die nächsten paar Monate durch eben die Neubildung von diesen EGA Antikörpern, also die vor allem im Rachen sind.
Aus dem Infektionsgeschehen ein bisschen rausgenommen. Ne, weil wir haben ja genau diesen Effekt, frische Impfung, Antikörperfahnen hoch,
um im Mund und Rachenbereich sozusagen so als als unmittelbare,
Alarmwirkung und nach eins, zwei, drei Monaten lassen die dann halt nach. Und das ist aber genau die Antikörper, die eben Infektionen einschränken.
Die anderen Antikörper gibt's immer noch, die im Körper sind. Die verhindern halt die Krankheit. Ja, die verhindern auch,
Infektionen in gewisser Hinsicht oder das fortschreitende Infektion oder beenden es dann auch früher et cetera. Also es hat alles seine Auswirkungen, aber eine frische Impfung,
ist immer hilfreich, weil der Körper in dem Moment halt noch mal in den Alarmmmodus geht, insbesondere den ersten,
zwei Wochen, ne, aber so zumindest für ein, zwei Monate hilft natürlich auch so eine Booster Impfung auch noch mal das Infektionsgeschehen zu beeinflussen, weil man eben nicht so aktiv dran teilnimmt. Selbst wenn's einem nicht geschadet hat, eine Infektion.
Na ja, also äh lasst euch bitte boostern, ja? Ich denke, die Hörerinnen und Hörer dieses Kanals muss man da eh nicht lange bitten. Das finde ich auch gut so.
Aber sagt's weiter, weil ich glaube viele Leute haben noch nicht begriffen, dass das jetzt geht. Ja, also nochmal, Booster angeht, geht am besten zum Impfzentrum, wenn ihr einzelne Nähe habt,
Ansonsten sprecht mit euren Ärzten. Jeder darf sich impfen lassen mit einer dritten Impfung, egal wie alt, solange zwölf plus natürlich.
Und es gibt da keinerlei Einschränkungen und es gibt auch keine Einschränkungen durch die, sondern dass es sozusagen einfach jeder kann das machen lassen.
Sollte es eben auch tun und ähm ja, ist genauso verträglich wie vorher auch schon.
Vielleicht auch noch so ein Ding äh nicht erwähnt hattest äh beziehungsweise hast du's erwähnt äh dass.
Die Booster halt dramatische Auswirkungen haben und insbesondere gibt's wohl aus Israel auch die Zahlen, dass das Risiko bei Älteren, also bei über 60-jährigen, um den Faktor 50 äh gesenkt.
Wird. Ähm,
so ähm ja äh also das das Risiko zu sterben. Äh so also gerade ähm also bei bei Älteren äh muss man sagen
unbedingt äh so oder so grade Ältere profitieren extrem davon, aber äh im Grunde genommen äh ja jeder. Also wahrscheinlich äh
dass zeigen die Zahlen aus Israel
dass ja man offenbar äh schon das ganze, ich sage mal, wegbustern äh kann jetzt die die aktuelle Welle.
Mhm. So. Jetzt äh haben wir aber natürlich noch ähm die Zweifler.
Und ähm ja. Die sind in allen Bereichen der Gesellschaft präsent, unter anderem Fußballspieler.
Es gab äh äh schon verschiedene Aufreger in verschiedene Leute, äh die sich ähm
unisono immer wieder in dieser selben Suppe aus Halbinformationen und Populismus äußern.
Was ich hier Sarah Wagenknecht im Fernsehen und äh auch dieser sogenannte Philosoph, dieser Precht und so, das sind halt alles so Leute.
Ja, nee, ich lasse mich nicht impfen, weil und dann irgendwie schlechte Erklärung.
Und richtig nochmal eine äh Rona hat es genommen als jemand, der überhaupt nicht als kompetent gelten darf, in diesem Bereich sich geäußert hat, nämlich der Bayern, Fußballspieler Kimmich.
Halt auch irgendwie.
Befragt wurde und dann meinte so, ja nee, er will sich ja nicht impfen lassen, weil er wartet ja nochmal ab wegen der Langzeit äh Folgen und man wüsste ja nicht.
Ja gut, also man muss es wahrscheinlich nochmal erzählen.
Einfach, weil's, glaube ich, auch so eine Information ist, die in dieser ganzen Geschichte am Ende auch irgendwo untergeht, ja, ist klar, nicht jeder Person,
folgt dem ganzen Informationsgeschehen, so wie wir das jetzt hier tun.
Oder folgt Leuten oder hört auf Leute oder steht überhaupt in Kommunikation mit Leuten, die das tun, sondern man kriegt halt so eine bunte Patchwork-Gemeingelage, Informationen.
Und zieht sich dann halt,
irgendwas raus und dann je nachdem, mit was für Leuten man so normalerweise zusammen ist, verstärkt sich dann eben das eine oder das andere oder es verstärkt sich alles auf einmal und in diesen ganzen Widersprüchen, die aus diesen Halbinformationen
zusätzlich mit der ganzen Propaganda von von rechts und aus diesem Schwubelkreisen die Leute dann halt auch einfach total verunsichert. Aber,
vielleicht mal diese eine Nummer, weil die wurde ja dann auch medial ganz gut aufgegriffen. Das fand ich irgendwie ganz gut. Also es hat dann insofern auch was bewirkt oder könnte was bewirkt haben.
Diese mehr von den Langzeitfolgen oder Langzeitschäden oder Langzeitwirkung und Impfstoffen.
Haben wir ja auch schon irgendwie X mal behandelt, aber,
Mittlerweile sind wir ja auch im Impfgeschehen soweit vorangeschritten weltweit, dass man das jetzt auch glaube ich wirklich ein für alle Mal zu den Akten legen kann. Also was steckt dahinter? Dahinter steckt so diese Angst.
Eine Impfung in irgendeiner Form, wenn man sie erhält, irgendwann.
Irgendwann in irgendeiner fernen Zeit Monate oder Jahre später vielleicht.
Eine negative Auswirkung hat. Das ist das ist so ein so ein so ein so ein Ding, was immer wieder rumgeht. Und da werden dann halt Fälle zitiert,
Wo das ja angeblich auch so gewesen sei. Und da haben wir ja auch schon mal drüber gesprochen.
Da kann man einfach nur sagen, die ist nicht so. Was da immer wieder kolportiert wurde, sind Fälle, wo Jahre später.
Aufgefallen ist, nachdem man eine überhaupt erst nennenswerte und wissenschaftlich relevante Zahl von Fällen gesehen hat, wo aufgefallen ist, dass ein Impfstoff,
innerhalb einer relativ kurzen Zeit eine negative Auswirkung gehabt hat und entsprechende Impfschäden hervorgerufen hat.
Ähm mit anderen Worten, was es.
So bisher noch gar nicht gab, waren Schäden, wo später aufgefallen ist, dass die sehr viel später aufgefallen sind.
Vorgekommen sind. Genau genommen geht man davon aus, dass solche.
Impfung einfach keinerlei Kapazität haben, nennenswert über einen Zeitraum von ein paar Wochen hinaus irgendeine Auswirkung auf den Körper zu haben.
Dazu sind einfach die verabreichten Dosierungen zu gering und äh werden dann halt auch irgendwann vom Körper
abgeborene Impfung ist halt eine sehr kurzfristige Reaktion des Körpers, die dann eben in der Folge
langfristig wirkende Antikörper aufbaut.
Aber die Impfung als solche, der Stoff, der einem da verabreicht wird, verpufft. Der ist dann halt bekämpft und weg.
Und es gibt keinerlei Erkenntnisse, dass dem irgendwie anders sei. Jetzt,
war natürlich bald der Corona-Impfung. Alles neu, ja, Krankheit neu, Impfung neu,
Impfstofftechnik auch neu. Das erzeugt natürlich auch erst mal eine gewisse Zurückhaltung. Das kann ich verstehen. Ähm und natürlich war auch hier jetzt die Frage offen.
Kann das was machen.
Nur ist es halt so, dass eben durch die Pandemie die Zahl der Fälle, die hier betrachtet werden konnten, schon in der Prüfung,
sehr viel höher war als bei allen anderen Impfstoffen zuvor, also man hat einfach mit 30, 40.000 Probanden gearbeitet und das nicht nur bei dem einen Impfstoff, sondern eben bei mehreren. Das ist schon eine sehr hohe Zahl und konnte dann eben, weil das äh,
Infektionsgeschehen eben so hoch war, auch innerhalb kürzester Zeit schon Aussagen machen über die Verlässlichkeit oder die Zuverlässigkeit beziehungsweise die die Wirksamkeit der Impfstoffe. Und in einem eingeschränkten Maße auch auf die Verträglichkeit.
Ja, um's ja oder um's vielleicht auch nochmal.
Von der anderen äh äh Seite herum äh zu sagen, mit anderen Worten äh so Langzeitwirkungen sind halt Wirkungen äh,
bei Impfungen, die mehr oder weniger unmittelbar auftreten, also innerhalb von Tagen oder Wochen.
Und dann lange anhalten möglicherweise, ja? Aber es sind eben keine Wirkungen, die sich nicht
sofort zeigen in irgendeiner Form, sondern es passiert nichts und äh irgendwie plötzlich Jahre später äh so,
passiert dann irgendwas. Dafür gibt es jetzt
keinen Wirkungsmechanismus äh wie das gehen sollte. Hans war jetzt ja, theoretisieren, okay, irgendwie beeinflusst so eine Impfung ja das das Immunsystem oder verändert das Immunsystem auch dauerhaft.
Aber äh es verändert das Immunsystem auf eine Art und Weise, wie es äh auch äh,
ja natürlich durch Viren oder andere pathogene äh
sich verändert, nämlich ähm ja, indem es sich darauf einstellt, diese zu bekämpfen und äh aus dem Körper zu schaffen und und und abzubauen, also insofern ist es jetzt nicht so
ähm dass wir jetzt direkt am Immunsystem rumschrauben so. Äh sondern wir geben ihm was zu futtern.
Und ja es reagiert dann eben entsprechend darauf.
Und es reagiert halt sofort und nicht irgendwie Jahre später, wenn das Futter nicht mehr da ist.
Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass nichts gefunden worden wäre. Wir hatten ja den Fall mit Astra äh Seneger,
Ja? Und wir hatten auch bei den mRNA-Impfstoffen eine entsprechende Unverträglichkeit gefunden, waren's halt diese ähm Hirn äh Thrombosen,
aufgetreten sind, dass also hier bei.
Wenigen Leuten, mit einer sehr geringen Wahrscheinlichkeit und vor allem junge Frauen waren davon betroffen, ähm eben tatsächlich.
Komplikationen, die unmittelbar auf die Impfung zurückzuführen waren, aufgetreten sind. Das mittlerweile auch schon ganz gut erforscht und davon weiß man und dann wurde ja auch das Impfregime entsprechend umgestellt, dass also dieser Impfstoff für
jüngere äh rausgenommen wurde aus dem Programm und mittlerweile wird überhaupt gar kein mehr verimpft.
Ähm und äh auch die seltenen Herzmuskelentzündungen, die aufgetreten sind bei den MRNA-Impfstoffen, sind gefunden worden.
Und das war's dann jetzt aber eigentlich auch im Wesentlichen. Wir haben viele Milliarden an Impfungen durchgeführt.
Ich weiß nicht, was ist jetzt die Gesamtzahl an ähm Impfungen, die insgesamt durchgeführt wurde.
Nochmal ganz kurz, damit ich nicht äh irgendeinen Unsinn erzähle, wie ich das sonst immer mache. Also.
Die Welt hat kulativ jetzt über 7 Milliarden.
Impfdosierung verimpft laut offiziellen Zahlen. Laut gemeldeten Zahlen und wahrscheinlich liegt die tatsächliche Zahl sogar noch ein bisschen drüber.
7 Milliarden. Innerhalb eines äh verhältnismäßig kurzen Zeitraums von noch nicht mal einem Jahr.
Es ist einfach sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass jetzt hier noch irgendwas kommt.
Kannst nicht komplett ausschließen. Ich sage nur, es ist eben sehr, sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich.
In Europa alleine so ohne UK waren's 861 Millionen Dosen mit
UK äh zusammen äh werden wir dann praktisch offene Milliarde Impfdosen allein in Europa, die äh da
ja verimpft worden sind und bei so.
Gewaltigen äh Zahlen äh praktisch die gesamte Bevölkerung äh durchgeimpft. So haben wir eigentlich jetzt ein ganz ganz gutes.
Bild äh davon und während ich noch gewisses Verständnis dafür gehabt hätte, wenn jemand im
Frühjahr noch gesagt hätte, hm, das ist mir aber unheimlich oder vielleicht sogar noch im Sommer äh äh gesagt hätte, hm äh nee, ähm
das mit diesen Sinus den Thrombosen und ähm ja mit den anderen Nebenwirkungen das verunsichert äh
mich so mittlerweile äh ist es so, äh dass man das nicht mehr,
aufrechterhalten äh kann, so äh.
Die, die mehr von ja Langzeitwirkungen oder äh das das das,
dass die Impfung gefährlicher sein könnte als die Krankheit. So, das hat sich irgendwie tausend Mal äh millionenfach viele, viele millionenfach
als äh eben nicht zutreffend rausgestellt und ja, äh ich habe auch immer gesagt.
Äh einen einen gewisses Risiko besteht, Impfschäden sind real. Menschen sind nun mal sehr, sehr unterschiedlich und vielfältig und wenn's in die Milliarden geht,
kann im Prinzip alles passieren in einzelnen Fällen, aber wir wissen, dass in den meisten Fällen halt,
schlichtweg äh.
Nichts passiert, außer, dass die Leute dann ähm sicherer sind vor Tod oder schweren Verläufen und ansonsten, ja.
Ähm insofern äh vielleicht noch auch äh ähm also es gibt.
Studien oder mal so.
Hinweise darauf, also hundertprozentig klar äh ist es nicht, weil sich das auch auch kaum nachweisen lässt, aber es gibt, ich sage mal, die eine begründete Vermutung, dass eine Reihe äh dieser schweren,
Fälle von Impfschäden aufgetreten sind, weil äh in den Fällen äh,
Impfstoff äh halt in eine Vene statt in den Muskel gespritzt worden ist. Das kann halt in wenigen Fällen kann das halt.
Passieren so, dass halt der Arzt dann oder der ihm
dünne Vene äh trifft und an sich oder früher
ähm hat man wohl grundsätzlich aspiriert, das heißt äh sagen die Nadel angesetzt und dann bisschen zurückgezogen, um zu sehen, ob,
Blut kommt, äh weil das ist dann das Zeichen, dass man eine wenige
hat und man dann sagen entweder ein bisschen weiter rein oder ein bisschen weiter raus äh geht
um um das, um das zu vermeiden. So und eigentlich gehört nämlich aber der Muskel halt in den in dem Impfstoff und klar wird ein bisschen dann auch ähm über den Kreislauf an andere äh Stellen transportiert.
Aber
ähm man weiß auch, dass der Großteil des Impfstoffs im Muskel verbleibt, an der Stelle äh im im Prinzip
ja ein, zwei Zentimeter um die Einstichstelle äh herum äh so und nun paar Prozent dann an andere Stellen des Körpers.
Äh äh wirklich gelangen von dem von dem Impfstoff.
Ja und das ist natürlich anders äh wenn äh das Ganze, wenn der Inhalt halt komplett in die Vene geht, dafür ist das ist sind die Impfstoffe eigentlich nicht ausgelegt
und äh da wissen wir halt auch nicht,
passiert und es wäre allerdings auch nicht ethisch, jetzt versuche zu veranstalten äh und den Impfstoff den Leuten in die Vene zu spritzen und zu gucken, ob sich dann äh ob's dann irgendwie schlimmer ist. Das kann man halt leider äh nicht machen, aber
wie gesagt, es gibt da halt ähm ähm eine Reihe von von.
Von von Medizinern, äh die das für sehr plausibel halten, äh dass ja, man da aufpassen muss und äh so als als Tipp äh äh vielleicht, ich.
Weiß gar nicht, ob bei den, ob bei meinen Shots habe ich halt nicht drauf geachtet, äh ob,
aspiriert wurde, weil ich halt nichts davon wusste zu dem Zeitpunkt, aber ich denke ähm ich werde mal darauf achten und es ist jetzt auch nichts äh äh es ist halt,
ein, zwei Sekunden, äh die das die das länger dauert und es gibt eigentlich,
aus meiner Sicht nicht wirklich ein Grund, warum das nicht Standard äh Prozedere sein äh sollte und äh ja, aber das ist vielleicht auch noch so ein so ein Ding, äh wo man dann,
ja den Impfenden vielleicht drauf aufmerksam machen kann, wobei zumindest im Ausland ich oft gehört habe, dass viele der Impfenden gar nicht wissen, was das ist so.
Aspiration. Beim beim Spritze setzen.
Mhm. Habe ich so jetzt auch nicht gesehen. War bei mir definitiv äh nicht der Fall. Das was so gemacht wurde. Aber ist mal ein interessantes Thema auf jeden Fall, das mal anzu.
Und es und es wird halt, wie gesagt, es äh also ich sind halt auch nicht dazu verpflichtet, das zu tun, also ich weiß, es lautet die,
offizielle Empfehlung. Äh nee, muss nicht, weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit auch eine Vene zu treffen, äh extrem gering ist. Also.
Ärzte äh von denen ich das gehört habe, meinten vielleicht eins von zehntausend Fällen oder so,
kommt es vor, dass man eine Vene trifft, ja. Also die, die dann ihr ganzes Leben lang aspiriert haben und viele tausend Spritzen äh gesetzt haben, so
ja meinten sie hätten es in ihrer Karriere ein, zweimal erlebt?
Vielleicht, dass sie eine Vene versehentlich getroffen haben, dass da wirklich was rausgekommen ist. Und wenn du natürlich jetzt, ich sage mal, zehn oder zwanzig Jahre lang aspirierst und da kommt nie was.
Äh
ist es natürlich verständlich äh komm. Lassen wir's, lassen wir's, ja. Aber wenn du natürlich jetzt eine Milliarde Leute durch
impft so. Dann ähm ist es vielleicht äh ja dann doch eine Überlegung
Wert äh dass das dann da doch Zahlen zusammenkommen plötzlich, wo es einen Unterschied macht.
Na ja, also äh äh also zumindest schadet es nichts, ja? Kann es nichts schaden? Äh zu aspirieren
aber ja, das ist äh so eine Debatte, ja das es ist auch unter Fachleuten ein bisschen umstritten, aber ich bin da
ich ich ich sehe unter Kostennutzen oder Kostenschadensabwägungen äh sollte man das meiner Meinung nach tun. Also ich glaube, den Ärzten, die da sagen,
Aspirieren sollte man tun.
So, was äh durch unseren äh Fußballspieler auch äh noch aufgebracht wurde, war dann glaube ich so diese diese Aussage.
Er würde ja dann noch irgendwie aufn auf einen Tod Impfstoff warten.
Und das ist dann auch gleich noch mal so ein so ein zweiter Bereich, wo man sagen muss so, hm, ja.
Weil worauf bezieht sich das? Also.
Ursprünglichen Impfstoffe, die Allerersten. Zum Beispiel war so ein.
Lebender Impfstoff, weil das halt sozusagen echte Kuhpockenviren waren.
Ja, die zwar äh nicht die Pocken ausgelöst haben, aber äh nagelnu dran waren, um eben so eine Immunantwort zu.
Aber im Prinzip war das so the real äh thing, ne? Und auch das, was heute noch bei Masern verimpft wird.
Ist ähm im Prinzip.
Auch noch so lebendige Zellen, die sind aber wie man so schön sagt, atinuiert, abgeschwächt.
Damit sie quasi eine Impfreaktion erzeugen, aber eben nicht sich weiter äh.
Vermehren können. Dafür ist es einfach zu schwach und das ist ja auch eine Impfung, die regelmäßig rausgegeben wird. Diese Tod-Impfstoffe wiederum sind dann eben.
Chemisch inaktivierte äh Viruspartikel, also nimmt man sozusagen Virus oder einzelne Virus äh Proteine.
Und ähm die werden dann halt durch einen chemischen Vorgang quasi abgetötet, aber tragen eben noch die Information, soweit das eben das äh Immunsystem darauf reagieren kann, nur,
Das Problem ist, dass die Reaktion eben nicht besonders gut ist. Also eigentlich gibt's überhaupt gar keine Reaktion,
Man muss quasi nochmal den Körper mit diesen sogenannten also mit solchen verstärkenden Zusatzstoffen, die dann erst mal die äh den die Immunantwort erstmal so überhaupt auf irgendwas,
nach dem Motto, hier ist was passiert, guck mal nach. Ja, das war so, was weiß ich, Aluminium.
Oder irgendwie so was, was noch beigegeben wurde. Nur ist dann auch die denn dann gibt's zwar eine Immunreaktion und die wendet sich dann eben auch gegen diese Viren.
An, nur ist sie nicht so stark.
Äh und du hast im besten Fall sowieso nur eine Antikörperantwort und äh hast so diese ganzen T-Zellen und sozusagen so diese richtig geile Reaktion des Körpers hast du dadurch irgendwie auch nicht, ne?
Weil ja das das Immunsystem ist nämlich schon echt schlau und und äh so, weil wenn du ja den.
Die toten Viren da an
bietest, die inaktivierten, sagt das äh Immunsystem erstmal, ne, ja, äh irgendwie Tote, Tote inaktivierte Viren, äh so der brauche ich jetzt, boah, jetzt keine Armee gegen ins Feld zu schicken, dat,
da träumen wir irgendwie, dass das das räumen wir mit der Straßenreinigung äh äh weg äh ja. So.
Und deswegen halt äh ja quasi das das Immunsystem äh muss man das auch noch anstacheln mit eben diesen,
hattest du,
äh äh Aluminiumverbindungen, das zu erwähnen, das mittlerweile gibt's da noch andere Dinge und ja, diese Wanzchen sind halt auch äh
nie ganz
unumstritten äh äh gewesen aus verschiedenen Gründen, auch weil sie merkwürdigerweise als Hilfsstoffe äh gelten und äh
damit äh halt eigentlich gar nicht als als Wirkstoffe.
So äh was was mir auch nie so ganz einleuchtend äh gewesen ist, aber gut. Äh ja unterm,
unterm Strich äh was dann sagen ja haben die neueren Impfstoffe,
äh da natürlich einen einen Vorteil. Äh plus ja oder vielleicht machst du jetzt.
Ja genau, darauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus. Also das ist quasi jetzt erst mal diese klassische Unterscheidung zwischen Lebend und und Tod-Impfstoffen. Nur im aktuellen Fall bei Corona.
Haben wir's eben mit keinem dieser beiden Varianten zu tun und
Die aktuellen Impfstoffe lassen sich eigentlich auch in diese Kategorisierung tot oder lebendig überhaupt nicht mehr richtig einordnen, weil einfach das Funktionsprinzip ein anderes ist. Dadurch, dass jetzt hier das Ganze in,
dem Deckmantel einer leicht modifizierten RNA eingeführt wird, ja? Also, also MRN, MRNA, also diese,
Messenger MRNA, quasi der Bauauftrag für die Zelle. Der, wenn er ja unmodifiziert wäre, also wenn man wirklich reine MRNA genau so, wie sie im Körper auftritt,
injizieren würde, auch vom Immunsystem sofort abgeräumt wurde, so nach dem Motto, was das denn hier weg,
Ja? Ist ja nur dieser kleine Trick dafür, wo es dann wahrscheinlich nächstes Jahr den Nobelpreis für geben wird, dieser leichten Modifikation.
Äh Sebastian als Türöffner funktioniert, dass der Körper das reinlässt, ohne die Codierung äh des Bauplans äh zu verändern.
Das ist ja der eigentliche Clou und das geht halt nicht in den Zellkern rein, ähm sondern geht einfach direkt in die Zelle und wird sofort produziert und die Reaktion darauf ist wiederum so gut wie auf ein Lebendimpfstoff?
Nur kann man eben jetzt hier nicht von einem lebenden Impfstoff im Sinne von.
Das ist der eigentliche Virus sprechen, sondern dass es halt auch nur ein Teil davon und deswegen ist das Ding einfach auf der einen Seite irgendwie tot, weil es.
An sich nichts macht, diese mRNA wird nur als Bauplan abgelesen und dann passieren Dinge, ja, macht nicht selber irgendetwas. Auf der anderen Seite ist aber die Wirkung davon so enorm, dass eben all diese ganzen anderen gewünschten,
Effekte auch eintreten, wie zum Beispiel der Aufbau,
T-Zellen und B-Zellen und und der gesamte Immun-Apparat wird halt gekickt und deswegen sind die Dinger halt auch so.
Erfolgreich. Deswegen sind diese Impfstoffe so hochgradig wirksam und übertreffen halt alles, was äh bisher da war und wir haben ja hier auch schon sehr viel über die mRNA Technologie als solche gesprochen und dass wir davon ausgehen.
Und nicht nur wir, sondern gleich sind die ganze medizinische Bereich, dass das quasi jetzt so ein bisschen auch die.
Die Zukunft von Medizin an sich ist, nicht nur Impfung. Ja, das ist ja eigentlich für was ganz anderes entwickelt worden. Man wollte da eigentlich eher in die Krebstherapie reingehen und dann kam halt Corona und gesagt so, probieren wir's mal und hat super funktioniert.
Also das ist halt auch so eine Annahme mit man also wer jetzt aufm Tod Impfstoff wartet.
Schon sagen, da wartet ihr lache, wird nicht kommen, weil wir haben schon was viel Besseres, das ist tot genug.
Hat überhaupt keinerlei nennenswerte äh Gefahren, ja, nennenswert im Sinne von statistisch signifikant.
Ausschließen kann man erst mal gar nix. Nur die Wahrscheinlichkeiten sind einfach mittlerweile so niedrig, dass es zu Probleme führt, dass man einfach immer sagen kann.
Wahl ist zwischen SARS-CoV-zwei in Reihenform, Infektionen mit den entsprechenden Auswirkungen oder halt einen Impfstoff.
Der nicht im Ansatz äh so schlimme Dinge mit äh euch anstellen kann, wie das Originalvirus und das ist äh die Wahl, die ihr habt und die ist meiner Meinung nach leicht zu beantworten.
Ja. Was ist eigentlich aus den Protein-Impfstoffen äh geworden.
Waren, hm?
Eine gute Frage. Ähm haben wir schon lange nicht mehr behandelt, aber ähm aktueller Stand ist tatsächlich, dass die jetzt ihre.
Zulassung gerade beantragt haben, sehe ich gerade.
In den U bei der EMA. Ah ja, genau. Das ist tatsächlich eine Nachricht von gestern Abend. Gut, dass du gefragt hast. Also Nova Wachs, das sind ja diese Protein-Impfstoffe, das ist ja quasi.
Ähm ja weiß ich nicht, wie soll man denn das nennen? Könnte das in dieser Kategorie tot lebendig irgendwie eine Rolle spielen?
Dass es eigentlich kommt sozusagen dem klassischen Tod Impfstoff am nächsten. Nur
mit dem Unterschied dass
jetzt nicht ich dass der Rohstoff nicht jetzt die Viren sind, die in Zellkulturen gezüchtet äh wurden, sondern äh dass halt einen Teil
äh äh der der Proteine ein Teil der Virus-Proteine. Ich glaube vor allem die Spike-Proteine irgendwie äh,
ja äh auf Basis von was war das, Mottenzellen oder so äh äh hergestellt werden und äh ja ähm,
Und insofern ja in in Kulturen von Mottenzellen so.
Und äh es werden virusähnliche Partikel formiert und das Endprodukt ist wohl ein kugeliger Nanopartikel auch und äh ja ähm
und äh sagen, da muss der Körper jetzt im Gegensatz zu den MRNA und Vektorvirus-Impfstoffen äh die Spike.
Proteine nicht herstellen, sondern das wird dann außerhalb des Körpers in Mottenzellen gemacht und man kriegt dann eben nur äh das Endprodukt,
in irgendeiner Form äh äh ja äh zugeführt und zusammen dann natürlich mit,
dann einen wobei sie ein neues namens Matrix M haben, wie man es sich glaube ich auch schon mal äh äh
erzählt äh habe und äh ja sie haben da eben da auch so einen leichten Bio-Touch gegeben, weil äh meinen, dass der Wirkverstärker aus den Rinden äh von Ästen älterer Bäume äh gewonnen
äh wird äh und so, sie ist Matrix M und ja und es kann angeblich auch als Booster
eingesetzt werden. So bin gespannt und es sollen 200 Millionen Dosen äh jetzt äh.
Äh kommen. Also EU hat sich 200 Millionen Dosen gesichert. Also äh ja.
Ähm man hat dann jetzt die Wahl,
Inzwischen einem äh zwischen jetzt milliardenfach äh verabreichten
bewährten Impfstoffen und einem neuen traditionellen Proteinstoff mit einem,
oder Wirkverstärker und ich sehe natürlich dann auch schon jetzt äh die ganzen
ja, ich sag mal Impfskeptiker dann umzuschwenken auf das äh so.
Ja, das kann man sich schon markieren im.
Nicht nicht passen und äh äh ja und äh insofern na ja ähm.
Kurze Korrektur vom Datum her, also von gestern ist die Nachricht, dass das Ding irgendwie in Neuseeland jetzt auch beantragt wurde. Ähm.
Und die Vorlage bei der EMA ist wohl ähm schon ein bisschen früher erfolgt. Ich kann's grad nicht so hundertprozentig sagen. Aber das ist sozusagen aufm Weg und wird dann vermutlich aber auch erst nächstes Jahr wirklich zum Tragen kommen.
Das dauert also noch eine Weile. Solange würde ich jetzt mal nicht warten. Erstmal lospustern und dann gucken, was passiert.
Tja, was machen wir jetzt mit unseren äh Fußballspielern? Das ähm so eine Sache, ne.
Ja, ich meine, ich hab's ja nun äh damals in der Piratenpartei auch,
bekommen, wie das ist. Äh wenn man.
So in der Öffentlichkeit steht und dann von Journalisten bedrängt wird, die natürlich immer äh das Ziel haben, aus einem irgendwas rauszulocken äh an Aussagen
ja äh dass dann Nachrichtenwert hat. So und ähm da kann man dann,
ja nur sagen, äh ich meine, wir haben dann damals, nach nachdem.
Halt äh wir naiv äh in ganz viele Fallen reingelaufen sind, uns dann eben auch professionelle Mediencoaches äh äh besorgt, die meistens,
auch äh ja Journalisten oder Ex-Journalisten sind und die halt das Spiel kennen äh so äh wie man dann von Journalisten angegangen wird und da ähm.
Äh 2 zwei Dinge,
Einmal lang als jemand, der in der Öffentlichkeit steht, sollte man sich stets bewusst sein, dass das, was man,
sagt, äh besonders ähm ja, gefährlich sein kann oder Wirkung hat, Wirkungen hat auf jeden Fall, weil das eben von vielen.
Rezipiert wird und äh so, das heißt
ja eine gewisse Vorsicht äh ist ist geboten als prominenter, weil das natürlich auch sehr schnell auf einen zurückfallen kann und weil äh ja ähm.
So äh und äh insofern muss man da halt einfach auch dann
lernen eben bestimmte Fragen einfach nicht zu beantworten. Also es gibt jetzt nicht die Pflicht irgendwo äh alle Fragen,
zu beantworten oder sich zu zu allem zu äußern und er ist da vielleicht auch ein bisschen in die Falle gelaufen. Auf der anderen Seite ist es ein hochbezahlter Profi, äh der jetzt glaube ich nicht sein erstes Interview,
geführt haben dürfte und ähm es gibt halt auch, glaube ich, noch viele andere Fußballer herausgestellt, die sich noch nicht,
haben impfen lassen, die aber dann wenigstens so klug waren, sich dazu nicht in der Öffentlichkeit zu äußern.
Ja, gab aber auch welche, die sich da auch äh trefflich geäußert haben. So gibt's ja auch hier diesen Fall von diesem Wort äh Wegrohr aus, diesen holländischen Spieler, der irgendwie ja auch äh.
Anhänger von Verschwörungstheorien ist, aber sagen wir mal das jetzt auch nicht besonders gut begründen konnte, äh warum er sich nicht impfen lassen möchte.
Dann neulich auch seine Corona-Infektion äh eingefangen, wie das ausgegangen ist, kann ich noch nicht sagen. Ähm
Ja klar, also ich meine, die stehen in der Öffentlichkeit, aber auf der anderen Seite, es sind Spitzensportler. Es sind Leute, die wirklich wo Körper und medizinische Begleitung einen sehr hohen Stellenwert hat.
Es ist nicht so, dass die jetzt irgendwie in der Buchhandlung arbeiten oder ist vielleicht noch nicht mal das beste Beispiel. Ein Supermarkt oder keine Ahnung, irgendwo halt wo das nicht so ein Thema ist, wo man nicht die ganze Zeit mit einem Medical-Team in Kontakt steht.
Aber können wir nicht erzählen, dass bei Bayern München keine ausgebildeten Ärzte rumlaufen? Warum warum können die nicht dafür sorgen,
Diese Spieler einfach mal up to date sind? Oder haben die da irgendwie auch so ein so ein.
Schwobelarm am Start, dass da äh äh nix geht. Das kann ja halt irgendwie nicht so richtig verstehen. Also man muss sich doch mit so was auseinandersetzen, insbesondere wo diese ganze Coronakrise für den eigenen Beruf,
so eine existenzielle Bedeutung auch hatte. Klar, Bundesliga war natürlich.
In gewisser Hinsicht auch privilegiert. Einfach ob der Bedeutung, die das irgendwie hat, ne? Sowohl,
was den wirtschaftlichen Wert betrifft, aber vor allem, was eben diesen diese hohe gesellschaftliche Akzeptanz betrifft, die es eben einfach hat, ja, kann man ja finden, wie man will, aber es ist halt einfach mal fax, dass irgendwie Fußballrelevanz hat.
Und dann muss man sich irgendwie mit solchen Sachen auch auseinandersetzen. Dann habe ich da ehrlich gesagt für so eine Haltung verhältnismäßig wenig.
Verständnis, so sie denn eben auf solchen grundlegenden, einfachen Missverständnissen der Gesamtsituation basiert, die man einfach mühelos innerhalb von 20 Minuten ein Gespräch mit einem Medical Team ausräumen könnte.
Also ich würde auch sagen dazu zu
zu sagen, so äh er kann jetzt nichts dafür. Ich hasse jetzt auch im Verweigerer oder oder Skeptiker äh nicht, ja, sondern die tun
mir halt eher leid, weil sie offensichtlich ein Modell von der Realität
im Kopf haben, was äh Sie und andere unnötig in Gefahr bringen,
und äh wenn sie das auch noch verbreiten, dann äh verdienen sie dafür halt Verachtung statt
Respekt äh so, ja oder beziehungsweise Verachtung für ihre Meinung äh so statt äh Respekt,
an der an der Stelle, aber äh ja ähm ich meine klar äh
Eigentlich soll's jedem klar sein, dass halt ein Fußballer Mitte zwanzig jetzt keine gute Quelle für Gesundheitsinformationen äh äh ist. Und ähm ja, aber letztlich
ja tun mir wie gesagt die Leute eher leid weil sie praktisch an einer Angststörung leiden äh die sie letztlich.
Selbst und anderen einer erhöhten Gefahr von Gesundheitsschäden aussetzt oder gar dem Tod aussetzt. So.
Es ist halt einfach nur ja tragisch, ne? Also es ist halt,
Tragisch an an der Stelle und äh ja, da hilft dann aber auch tatsächlich nur gesellschaftlicher Druck und eine klare Ansage, so, nee.
Ist nicht okay. Ich meine, meinetwegen okay, selbst äh ja, wenn du an dieser Angststörung leidest und das nicht behandeln äh lassen willst oder nichts daran ändern willst,
meinetwegen, ja, aber renne jetzt nicht noch rum und äh mache irgendwie andere Leute kirre. Bitte. Nur weil du irgendwie nicht klarkommst.
Ja, dass nicht alle im Fußballsport sich jetzt auch auf dieselbe Art und Weise äh zu solche Fragestellungen äußern, insbesondere wenn sie sich bewusst sind, dass sie in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, beweist äh ein ums andere Mal Jürgen Klopp,
spiel mal kurz äh ein, was er äh erwidert hat. Als Journalisten ihn zur Einschätzung der Coronakrise im letzten Jahr, muss man sagen, ist jetzt äh nichts aktuelles, schon eine Weile her,
geäußert hat, aber das passt an dieser Stelle glaube ich ganz gut rein.
Ja, also als Englischlehrer würde auch nicht durchgehen, aber definitiv die Rolle als ähm Arzt lehnt er ab und das irgendwie mal ein klares äh Statement.
Ja.
Was fragt ihr mich? Richtig so.
Ich meine, wo wir natürlich jetzt gleich dann die Frage aufhaben, okay und was ist jetzt mit uns, was qualifiziert uns eigentlich jetzt äh hier zu dem Thema zu reden und äh äh wenn sich jemand jetzt
diese Frage stellt, denn ja, wir sind jetzt nun wieder auch äh äh also keine Ärzte. So aber äh ich äh denke.
Also wir haben jetzt vor ja fast zwei Jahren äh im Grunde genommen angefangen
einfach sehr viele Informationen zu dem Thema uns zusammenzusuchen, zu gucken welche Informationen haben sich als äh glaubwürdig,
bestätigt
nachgerechnet und verfolgen äh das Ganze jetzt äh schon eine ganze Weile und sind dadurch äh glaube ich auch immer mutiger geworden äh einfach uns dazu zu äußern, weil wir sagen mal sowohl von,
Experten aus dem äh Bereich aller Professionen und eben ganz vielen Leuten so viel positives Feedback.
Bekommen haben und ich glaube, dass wir hier denke ich, ich hoffe äh zumindest äh relativ,
verantwortungsvoll mit den Informationen umgehen, die wir hier äh verbreiten. Wir haben da auch äh glaube ich nicht nicht immer allerbeste Erfahrungen gemacht, aber ich glaube,
ähm im großen und und Ganzen ist ist mein Eindruck, dass äh wir hier relativ wenig Unsinn verbreiten.
Oder.
Das ist äh vielleicht ein berechtigter Eindruck. Ist auf jeden Fall meine Hoffnung. So, wir uns auf jeden Fall. Und an die kann ich nur sagen, Research.
Ja und äh versuchen halt auch äh immer wieder zu gucken äh so äh was haben wir vielleicht falsch eingeschätzt? Was hat sich als falsch äh äh erwiesen im Nachhinein? Und da ist zumindest mein
Eindruck äh so äh
kann sich unsere Bilanz auch sehen lassen. Ich meine, jeder kann's sich anhören, sogar es gibt sogar Transkripte, also ich kann dann irgendwelche Wissenschaftler oder KIs in in
einigen Jahren äh das dann mal automatisiert durcharbeiten lassen, die 100 Stunden und mal mal einen Faktencheck
äh äh machen. Was sind so in diesen hundert Stunden da alles verbreitet haben. Ja ähm ich guck
gucke hier gerade noch äh in den in den Twitter-Shread äh rein, die nicht die nicht zum Thema Kimmich geschrieben habe, was die Leute da noch geantwortet haben.
Und da war so ein ein ein Ding wo.
Wohl irgendwie unter anderem Kimmich dann auch äh Kinder auf der Krebsstation besucht hat.
Ungeimpft, ja.
Ja, es ist jetzt vielleicht auch nicht so grade, ich meine, es scheint jetzt nichts Schlimmes passiert zu sein und äh trägt auch eine Maske irgendwie, alle tragen Masken und so.
Aber äh ja äh also sofern dann ja auch.
Genau allen
Hinweis, die nur auch grad schon gebracht, dass was sie denn für Ärzte beim FC Bayern haben, dass sie dem das nicht erklären können, ja. Vernünftig oder wie das Vertrauensverhältnis dann eigentlich zu seinen Ärzten äh zu sein scheint. Ja
andere, ich meine, etwas zynische äh Bemerkungen waren dann noch eine eher Hochleistungssportler spritzen eigentlich gewöhnt sein. Ja, das ist jetzt ein bisschen bösartig. So.
Und ähm ja ansonsten ähm,
denke ich, was auch jetzt.
Belassen, was was Kimmich angeht und einfach nur hoffen, dass äh ihm jemand vielleicht die Angst nimmt und äh ja äh und auch vielen anderen Leuten, die vielleicht Angst haben.
Sich einfach den Ruck geben und es und es probieren und äh ja dann weniger Angst vor dem Virus haben müssen.
Genau.
So, jetzt wo wir schon auf den im Bereich der Metadiskussion angekommen sind, wollen wir vielleicht zum Ende auch noch mal so die eigentliche Frage diskutieren, die auch.
Viel von äh euch gefragt wurde nämlich so dieses was.
Eigentlich die richtigen Maßnahmen zu diesem Zeitpunkt ähm sowohl.
Um halt Leute vom Impfen zu überzeugen oder was auch bisschen die Gründe sind, warum sie das vielleicht noch nicht so richtig hinbekommen haben.
Es äh ist natürlich.
Verschiedenes jetzt auch ausprobiert worden, wo ich mir jetzt selber auch nicht mehr so richtig sicher bin, ob das so eine gute Idee war, auch wenn ich sie selber vielleicht am Anfang unterstützt habe, zum Beispiel bin ich mir grad nicht so sicher, ob der Move die.
Die Schnelltests ähm kostenpflichtig zu machen.
Unterm Strich wirklich hilfreich ist, weil's ja auch nicht unbedingt dazu geführt hat, dass mehr Leute zur Impfung gehen, also dieser dieser Druck scheint nicht,
so richtig zu helfen. Auf der anderen Seite sind wir zumindest in Deutschland immer noch relativ klar auf dieser Position mit, ja, an die Impfpflicht, nein?
Wobei ich schon den Eindruck habe, dass in der Debatte da die Front dahingehend bröckelt, dass.
Impfpflicht für bestimmte Bereiche sehr wohl ähm vermehrt diskutiert.
Wenig überraschend gewesen, dass solche spaltenden Themen ein bisschen rausgehalten wurden, solange wir noch in diesem Wahlkampf waren.
Und jetzt nach dem Wahlkampf haben wir natürlich wieder um dasselbe Problem, dass all diese ganzen Debatten so richtig keinen Adressaten haben. Haben wir ja irgendwie so einen,
Jens Spahn, so einen scheidenden Gesundheitsminister, der sich dann hinstellt und sagt so, ja, jetzt wäre doch hier mal irgendwie Freedom Day äh doch mal demnächst angesagt und er sieht jetzt hier irgendwie keine.
Formuliert, er sieht jetzt keine die Notfallsituation der Pandemie wäre ja jetzt irgendwie vorbei, wo ich mich halt auch nur frage so.
Aha, guckst du dir die Zahlen eigentlich jetzt äh an oder irgendwie hast du ein Poster von vorm Sommer am an der Wand hängen und das das gilt jetzt einfach.
Merkt man auch schon, dass sie sich in zunehmendem Maße so in so eine innere Opposition zurückziehen.
Gar nicht mehr so richtig als Minister und entscheidende Personen argumentieren, sondern,
schon mal so äh in den Schützengraben gehen, um sich dann quasi so aus der Opposition heraus mal wieder so die ganzen Gegenpositionen, die gerade so,
angesagt sind zu eigen zu machen und jetzt bloß nicht zu weit nach vorne lehnen. Auf der anderen Seite hast du eben jetzt die kommende äh Regierung, von der noch keiner genau weiß
jetzt hier eigentlich welchen Posten stellt und das Ganze soll ja dann auch erst im Anfang Dezember, glaube ich, ne, haben sie gesagt, wollen sie fertig sein? Sechster zwölfter oder irgendwie so was?
Sprich,
Wir erleben jetzt auch noch einen weiteren Monat eigentlich in der kompletten Führungslosigkeit, wo niemand bereit ist, in irgendeiner Form unpopuläre Maßnahmen zu ergreifen und dann haben wir halt wieder den Salat. Ich bin mal einen kurzen Clip ein,
das äh kommt von aus Bayern, das irgendwie eine eine Picar vom Ministerpräsidenten.
Söder und seinem Gesundheitsschutzminister äh Klaus.
Äh zur Einschätzung der aktuellen Situation. Da kam dann Folgendes.
Geil, oder? Also, das muss man erst mal bringen, ne.
Ja macht jetzt voll die Laschet äh irgendwie.
Ja. Klaus Holetscheck. Klingt so ähnlich.
Also ja es war alles äh vorhersehbar. Also keiner ist bereit irgendwas zu tun und jetzt sind wir wieder genau da, wo wir immer bei den anderen Wellen auch waren, genau vor einem Jahr, bei der zweiten Welle,
dann halt auch nochmal bei der dritten Welle immer dasselbe, so ah ja was wie wirklich? Ach so die ganzen Vorhersagen der Experten, die äh.
Stimmen dann auch so würde ich jetzt keiner rechnen. Also das Prinzip Hoffnung.
Diese ganze Debatte und man will halt nicht irgendwie moven und wenn dann irgendwie das alles nicht mehr so richtig zu leugnen ist, weil Krankenhäuser voll, andere Auswirkungen.
Dann war das ja alles überhaupt nicht vorher selber. Also total überraschend. Da ging die Tür auf, wie Corona, das war doch früher.
Wirklich ein bisschen haarig. Aber die Frage ist, was machen wir jetzt eigentlich? Was,
sind die richtigen Maßnahmen, brauchen wir so was wie in den USA, wo der Staat gesagt hat, große Unternehmen, die mit uns zusammenarbeiten, wenn da nicht alle Mitarbeiter äh geimpft sind, dann zack und dann kommt United Airlines und sagt, so.
Hat noch nicht und wer dann irgendwie bis zum Stichtag äh keine Impfung nachweisen kann, fliegt einfach und dann werden da halt auch einfach mal ein paar hundert Mitarbeiter ähm.
Gemacht. So und so was hätten wir ja in Deutschland auch haben können, aber wir haben halt hier immer noch das ähm.
Das das Dogma das solche hm Impfpflichten in bestimmten Berufsbereichen einschließlich der Pflege.
Nicht angemessen zu sein scheint. Und was hatten wir jetzt letzte Woche für einen Fall? Ungeimpfte Pfleger in einem Altenheim, wo dann wie viele Leute gestorben sind, 14 oder so was in der Größenordnung.
Mia ja ähm meine letzte Zahl war zwölf äh so, aber ich glaube, das ist seitdem noch angestiegen. Also es stieg dann täglich noch äh seitdem. Ja. Mhm.
Also hast du eine Meinung, was wir jetzt äh eigentlich tun und lassen sollten? Gibt's überhaupt noch Maßnahmen, die wir ergreifen können, nachdem sich äh die gesamte Gesellschaft auf Lockdown darf's nicht mehr geben, geeinigt hat?
Also ich meine, die sieht Situation ist.
Ethisch kompliziert. Würde ich äh würde ich mal äh sagen und nicht,
nicht ganz so eindeutig wie in den meisten Fällen in der Realität äh so ist. Die Realität halt ist halt selten schwarz und weiß. Ab und zu ist es sie
aber eben auch auch nicht immer und ähm so ja und es gab,
natürlich auch durchaus,
die berechtigte Hoffnung, dass es von paar Monaten äh das jetzt mit den Impfungen und so, dass das.
Schon gut gehen könnte irgendwie, aber dann gab's natürlich auch schon äh zumindest in den letzten Wochen dann ganz klare Signale aus den anderen,
Ländern, vor allem aus Israel, so äh nee. Äh so ähm zwei Impfungen reichen nicht,
Booster hatten wir so. Das zeichnete sich also schon mal schon mal ganz klar ab so. Zur.
Zu der ethischen äh äh Geschichte. Ich
denke erstmal grade in Deutschland, wo Mediziner und Medizin äh historisch,
auch ähm ja
nicht immer auf der richtigen Seite standen das Thema das halt im dritten Reich Mediziner glaube fünf bis zehn Mal höher,
Also wahrscheinlich Havan irgendwie Nazis zu sein als in anderen Berufsgruppen und so, also ähm
Ja äh und das deswegen äh äh glaube ich, wenn's so um Eingriffe in den in den Körper äh gibt,
geht, die halt äh,
ähm ja vorgeschrieben werden oder unter Androhung von Strafe erfolgen, muss ich sagen, da sehe ich für mich einfach eine absolute
Grenze, wo ich sagen würde, also
Impfung per jetzt ich sag mal Strafandrohung so nach dem Motto gibt's ja auch wenn du dich nicht impfen lässt musst du halt Strafe bezahlen äh oder.
Ähm keine Ahnung, wirst vielleicht noch eingesperrt, wenn du die Strafe dann nicht bezahlst. So äh das,
also das kann's nicht sein. Auf der anderen Seite äh wenn es eben gute jetzt,
Sachgründe gibt jetzt Menschen äh zu schützen und eben in beenden Berufen ja auch schon das das Thema seit eigentlich völlig normal, dass man in bestimmten Berufen,
arbeitet, wo ähm,
eine Infektion äh sich dann übertragen kann, dass sie sich in der Lebensmittelindustrie, in der Gastronomie, aber dann eben auch, wenn man ja äh Kranke oder verwundbare Menschen
äh betreut, dann ähm.
Kann äh das aus meiner Sicht anders aussehen und dann kann man natürlich solche begründeten Forderungen auch aufstellen, dass jemand bestimmte Tätigkeiten nur ausüb,
hm äh darf, äh wenn er geimpft ist. So. Ja? Ähm jetzt.
Tierpfleger zum Beispiel. Tierpfleger müssen gegen alles Mögliche geimpft sein zu ihrem eigenen Schutz. Wenn sie mit Tieren arbeiten wollen.
Und auch wenn du äh in Laboren mit bestimmten jetzt Pathogen oder Viren oder so umgehst, glaube ich, ist das auch der Fall. Oder wenn du Soldat bist,
ja, da wirst du nicht gefragt, ob du geimpft werden willst, so. Das da wird dir reingehauen, was,
immer äh irgendwo erforderlich ist äh um äh an deinen Einsatzort äh äh zu gelangen. Ja, da wird also beim Militär wird gar nicht gefackelt so. Ähm.
Oder ja in der Schifffahrt, äh wenn du irgendwie auf Schiffen unterwegs äh bist, Seeleute.
Ja werden einfach nicht von Bord gelassen oder nicht an Bord gelassen, wenn ihr nicht gegen bestimmte äh Krankheiten geimpft.
Von daher ähm ja äh sehe ich da, ich sage mal, aus aus ethischer äh Sicht äh.
Jetzt nicht das Problem. Es gibt aber natürlich wieder im Gesundheitswesen äh noch ein spezifisches Problem.
Ähm erstmal, dass es dort halt schon äh sehr, sehr wenig Leute gibt in der einer kranken und Altenpflege und man auch so Probleme hat,
überhaupt
Leute äh ranzukriegen, die die Jobs äh machen und wenn man davon jetzt, weiß ich nicht, noch zehn oder zwanzig Prozent äh mehr werden's nicht sein, äh die die sich nicht nicht impfen äh
lassen, aber wenn man die jetzt quasi vor die Tür setzt, ähm,
dann hat man äh unter Umständen äh noch ein schlimmeres Problem, weil man dann äh und dann steht man halt äh vor der Frage, ähm,
lässt lässt man die Leute gar nicht betreuen oder wird betreut dann
Ja also bricht das Ganze dann möglicherweise zusammen und das war an einigen Stellen in der in den USA auch tatsächlich so ein bisschen ein ein Problem.
Äh wo äh ja beiden.
Von von der Bundesebene her zumindest das ganze gefahren hat, äh dass dass da die Anforderungen ja da war, dass äh.
Im Prinzip alle Unternehmen, die irgendwie mit der Bundesregierung äh zusammenarbeiten, dass deren,
Mitarbeiter geimpft sein müssen. Und ja, das ist das brodelt da noch und halt auch in den USA für.
Sehr viel äh Unruhe und und Ärger gesorgt.
Ähm ja äh was was tun? Ähm ja ich,
Siehe nach wie vor impfen und Boostern äh ist der.
Praktikabelste und mit den wenigsten Schmerzen äh und Kosten verbundene äh Weg,
das Ganze ja unter Kontrolle zu kriegen. Und ähm.
Wenn wir das jetzt nicht machen, äh so.
Oder oder nicht nicht hinbekommen, dann werden wir halt wieder äh Lockdowns und Einschränkungen,
öffentlichen Lebens kriegen, äh wobei da es dann so ein bisschen das Problem gibt,
dass die unter Umständen so für
Geimpfte oder geboostete äh dann äh eigentlich nicht wirklich angemessen äh äh sind oder ja nicht
nicht möglicherweise rechtlich gar nicht durchgesetzt werden könnten. Das ist ist auch noch so ein bisschen unklar, aber es sieht danach aus, als wenn sagen sich die die Juristen
Verfassungsjuristen in diese Richtung bewegen würden.
Ja funktional sehe ich das jetzt so äh sagt auf der einen Seite wenn die Leute jetzt nicht mit Strafandrohung äh äh dazu zwingen aber alle
anderen Maßnahmen irgendwo entweder ein bisschen Druck auf die Leute auszuüben.
Oder natürlich idealerweise Schwellen äh zu senken ähm die die Leute nehmen müssen. Es gibt bestimmt,
immer noch auch ganz viele Leute, die es einfach verpeilt haben oder die keine Lust haben oder die Angst vor Spritzen haben, ähm so aus tausend
anderen Gründen, aber
ja zentral wäre es wahrscheinlich irgendwie diese irrationalen Ängste zu bekämpfen, die die Leute davon abhalten, sich sich impfen.
Zu lassen. So das wäre eigentlich ideal und im Grunde genommen müsste man da ja.
Äh vielleicht ein bisschen noch mehr Brain Power äh draufwerfen auf die Frage, äh wie man das denn jetzt hinkriegt, wie man sagen den Schalter äh in den Köpfen umgelegt kriegt, äh dass die Leute,
erkennen, ja, das hilft mir und das hilft anderen so. Ähm,
und da geht sicher mehr als wir als wir da der derzeit tun aber wird zum Glück sind Leute jetzt auch nicht nur reine Marionetten.
Aber ich glaube.
Einer gezielten Ansprache von bestimmten Leuten äh ja auch fragt, ist das jetzt denn.
Ethisch vertretbar im Grunde genommen dasselbe zu machen oder Ähnliches zu machen, was halt bestimmte Gruppen gemacht haben, um die Brexit-Abstimmung zu manipulieren. Ähm so,
ähm dass äh ob man das jetzt tun kann, also Grunde genommen ähm.
Die ungeimpften identifizieren so über was weiß ich, Facebook oder sonstige Daten oder über was sie halt auf Twitter äh gesagt haben und dann halt äh gezielt äh,
diese Leute in Formationen aussetzen, ähm die halt dann den Schalter äh umlegen und da,
kann man natürlich auch auf schwarze oder weiße Art machen. Ähm so, aber da gibt es äh ja
äh es es gibt in der Psychologie mittlerweile auch recht gut ausgearbeitete äh ähm Verhaltens,
Veränderungstechniken so, die halt therapeutisch vor allem eingesetzt werden, wo man äh ja auf ähm sage mal psychologische Art und Weise auf die Leute einwirkt,
ihr Verhalten äh zu ändern. Das funktioniert natürlich zum Glück auch nicht zu hundert Prozent, aber äh ja also wahrscheinlich ähm müsste man irgendwie solche,
Methoden ähm dann einsetzen, wenn man jetzt die Impfbereitschaft äh steigern möchte.
Ähm ja Schulen, Schulbildung natürlich langfristig äh hilft natürlich immer äh so, aber.
Wenn jemand jetzt äh völlig in eine andere Richtung abgebogen ist, so kriegst du den halt.
Rationaler Ansprache da in der Regel nicht raus. Da musst du dir dann schon ein bisschen mehr einfallen lassen.
Ja gut, ist halt auch die Frage, ob man das dann mit einer irrationalen Ansprache äh schafft so, ne? Und inwiefern.
Ja
Pflichten dann halt äh eher kontraproduktiv sind sogar noch.
Ich meine ähm Leute sind alle anfällig für Angst. Also äh insofern war ja irgendwie.
Muss sie nur eben noch.
Angst begegnen
äh so, aber das äh ist äh ja, aber das ist nicht wahrscheinlich nicht so äh wie man ich bin da jetzt auch nicht ja sozusagen
alles andere als jetzt ein Profi in äh Verhaltens äh Modifikationstechniken, aber ähm ja
es gibt welche.
Ich meine.
Impfen ist das eine, ne? So und jetzt können wir davon ausgehen, dass wir da noch einen Weg finden, die Impfbegeisterung la Bremen noch weiter zu schüren, ja, dass man sagt, hier wir lernen für den Besten und jetzt machen wir hier irgendwie mal
dass das Bremer Modell äh versuchen wir irgendwie deutschlandweit äh zumindest in Ansätzen voranzubringen. Kann sein, dann bringt das noch mal ein paar Prozent
uns aber jetzt nicht aus der Situation heraus, dass jetzt diese vierte Welle ähm auch grad so bisschen das Potenzial hat, wieder ein bisschen länger zu dauern.
Ne, weil wir haben jetzt nicht den Sommer vor der Tür. Wir haben nicht eine hohe Bereitschaft in der Politik irgendwas wirklich zu machen.
Äh auch eine neue Bundesregierung, wenn sie denn dann eingesetzt ist, äh will wahrscheinlich auch nicht gleich zu Beginn,
gleich wieder äh unpopuläre Maßnahmen ans Bein binden, ne, obwohl das wahrscheinlich eigentlich genau das ist, was sie äh äh tun sollte. Die andere Frage ist ja, geht man jetzt mit Einschränkungen.
Im öffentlichen Leben den Weg, ne? Also die 2G,
3G, ein G, was du auch immer für ein G äh äh Diskussion, also die richtige Kombination aus äh Testen und und und nicht Zugängen für bestimmte Leute.
Das sind halt jetzt äh Fragestellungen, die im Raum sind und derzeit haben wir so ein Patchwork ähm wiederum aus Landesregelungen, ja, zwei G heißt nicht überall das Gleiche bei Veranstaltungen.
Mal gilt nur für die Zuschauer, mal gilt es für das komplette Team und dann irgendwie auch noch für alle äh Servicedienstleister, die in irgendeiner Form drin beteiligt sind. Wer soll das überprüfen? Wie können die Unternehmen das überhaupt überprüfen?
Überhaupt gar keine Überprüfungspflicht äh oder Erlaubnis gibt, ne? Also man darf niemanden.
Ähm zu zwingen Impfstatus zu nennen, ne, auf der anderen Seite kann man sie auffordern, ein äh Impfnachweis zu liefern, wenn sie das nicht tun, kann man natürlich dann irgendwas annehmen, aber es ist halt auch
generell schwierig und ich glaube, äh in der Wirtschaft ähm geht es jetzt auch gerade äh rum, der Wunsch dann doch an der Stelle,
mal die Gesetzgebung dahingehend zu ändern, dass äh so ein Impfstatus sehr wohl abgefragt werden kann. Ehrlich gesagt, das ist auch etwas, wo ich sagen muss.
Doch das muss einfach zur Gefahrenabwehr muss so was einfach drin sein. Ich meine, der Staat hat sich dem verschrieben,
die Menschen zu äh schützen, gerade vor solchen Pandemien. Ja, das ist einfach so eine klassische Staatssituation.
Und der Staat kann sich an der Stelle jetzt nicht rausreden und sagen ja ach nee, also wir wollten euch ja auch alle schützen, aber äh Datenschutz.
Ja, das ist so.
Ja
Eine schwierige Situation, wo man wo man zumindest mal praktisch drüber nachdenken muss so. Was ist denn eigentlich die Argumentation dafür? Wie soll denn quasi ein Unternehmen aus seiner eigene Verantwortung für die Mitarbeiter wahrnehmen, wenn,
ist noch nicht mal die Datenlage dafür gibt. Oder geben kann.
Mhm. Ähm also.
Es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Unternehmen.
Die da recht pragmatische Lösungen für finden oder gefunden haben.
So ähm so ein äh
ein Beispiel ist jetzt eine eine Firma die sind dafür dann auch natürlich wieder voll in den sozialen Medien gebashed äh worden aber
die haben halt im Aufenthaltsraum eine LIST, ein ein.
Ein Plakat mit den Fotos von allen Ungeimpften.
Aufgehängt. So mit eben der Maßgabe hier äh in dem Raum.
Sagen solange dort äh nur Geimpfte sind so,
keine Masken getragen zu werden im im ja in der Kaffeeküche, Aufenthaltsraum, aber wenn eben einer von den Ungeimpften äh dabei sind, äh gilt halt 3G.
Nebenraum, ja, sozusagen so eine, so eine äh,
2G, 3G-Regelung, flexibel abhängig, wer davon jetzt in dem in dem Raum ist quasi so. Und.
Irgendjemand abfotografiert dieses Plakat, so nach dem Motto, ah irgendwie, hier Steckbrief für Ungeimpfte und sich irgendwie dann beim Datenschutzbeauftragten beschwert. Und der Datenschutzbeauftragte,
hat dann aber gesagt, nö.
Ist okay, weil äh vorher äh die Firma die Zustimmung äh aller Mitarbeiter für dieses Vorgehen.
Eingeholt hat und alle.
Insbesondere natürlich auch die Ungeimpften, dem einfach zugestimmt haben. Ja, weil da stand jetzt auch kein Name drunter oder so, sondern es ging halt eigentlich nur, also es ging nur
um den Zweck, um dass die anderen Leute feststellen können, ob's jetzt irgendwie 2G oder 3G machen müssen. Und das war dann halt, sage mal, datenschutzrechtlich.
Auch völlig in Ordnung diese Vorgehensweise will, sagen man kann sich halt.
Durchaus auch einfach einigen, zumindest in kleinen Unternehmen so groß große Unternehmen haben da natürlich ein Problem. Die brauchen da irgendwie eine einheitliche Regelung.
Aber andere Sache halt im ja im Motorradclub halt gestern eine eine Versammlung ähm abends
so und da war auch die Frage, sowas was machen wir jetzt irgendwie? Zwei G oder drei G und da haben wir halt einfach die Ansage gemacht, okay, wir würden gerne irgendwie 2G machen so
auf der Sitzung und wenn aber jemand teilnehmen möchte, der nicht geimpft ist, dann möge er das äh bitte irgendwie vorher
ankündigen äh und dann machen wir halt 3G. So. Ist halt dann keiner gekommen, der ungeimpft war.
Das sind aber keine Lösungen, die du jetzt in großen Konzernen in irgendeiner Form.
Nein nein, das kannst du das geht nicht
Es geht äh sicherlich in großen Konzernen nicht, aber in, ich sage mal, ganz ganz vielen jetzt äh Kleinunternehmen oder äh ja
ist das ist es zumindest äh man kann sich auch einfach einigen und man kann irgendwie auch miteinander reden und äh man muss das jetzt dann auch nicht zu sehr zuspitzen oder oder zu sehr
politisieren jetzt in einem Unternehmen, wo die Leute irgendwie zusammenarbeiten äh äh wollen und so. Ja.
Ja gut, aber äh das sind das, ich meine, das sind so jetzt so Teillösungen, ne. Wir brauchen ja generelle Lösungen. Wir brauchen Lösungen für die Läden. Wir brauchen Lösungen für Veranstaltungen.
Dadurch, dass jetzt die vierte Welle kommt und meiner Auffassung nach auch das Potenzial hat.
Nicht nur jetzt mal wieder so eine Welle zu sein, sondern das kann halt im schlimmsten Fall uns auch einfach den ganzen Herbst und Winter wieder verhageln.
Also es wird jetzt nicht so sein wie vor einem Jahr, ne, live goes on, so tralala, aber die Auswirkungen werden halt da sein und man muss sich halt jetzt fragen, wie weit wollen wir das jetzt noch durcheskalieren lassen, weil.
Die hohen Zahlen, die wir jetzt haben und ich glaube, wir hatten heute allein die Tagesmeldung war heute, glaube ich, der höchste Wert.
Bisher überhaupt jemals hatten an einem Tag an Neuinfektionen ne mit irgendwie dreiunddreißigtausend. Das gut das nivelliert sich jetzt so ein bisschen über die Tage und so aber äh da steckt auch grad eine ganze Menge äh Musik drin.
Ähm wenn das jetzt einfach so weitergeht und problematisch wird, dann bedeutet das halt wieder, dass eben du super Einschränkungen hast.
Für Unternehmen, für Arbeitsplätze, wo Leute einfach äh arbeiten und.
Diese Einschränkungen wiederum, in dem Moment, wo du sagst, ungeimpfte raus? Da gibt's dann halt auch so Branchen.
Ätzen sofort auf und sagen so, ey, äh Castro arbeitet sowieso grade gar keiner mehr.
Restaurants, die müssen einfach zumachen, weil die einfach kein Personal mehr haben oder müssen ihre Zeiten einschränken oder oder müssen halt auch komplett schließen.
Weil nur noch die Besitzer da äh,
quasi die Arbeit machen, völlig durch sind und überhaupt nicht in der Lage sind, äh so viel zu öffnen oder so viel Gäste zu bewirten, um überhaupt noch auf die eigenen Kosten zu kommen. Und das ist halt in der Veranstaltungs äh Branche.
Ähnlich und das ist ein totales Dilemma. Ich sehe das ja auch. Andererseits hast du halt eben auch keine Bereitschaft ähm universell jetzt auf zwei G zu gehen. Also es gibt,
zum Barbars, die sagen einfach, ja, 2G, wir stellen uns da Türsteher hin und bei uns würden irgendwie auch wirklich jedes Zertifikat überprüft und zwar richtig mit irgendwie auf einen Ausweis gucken und wir schaffen jetzt hier quasi so Selfspaces für.
Für Geimpfte, für die Leute, die irgendwie bereit sind, sich äh und andere zu schützen.
Aber es scheint mir nicht ein Modell zu sein, was generell übertragbar ist und das ist so ein bisschen das das Problem, was derzeit in dieser ganzen Debatte drinsteckt, dass egal wie du's machst, du irgendjemanden äh vorm Kopf stößt.
Letzten Endes klar, wissen wir auch alle, der Grund dafür sind die Leute, die nicht bereit sind, sich zu impfen. Ja, also wir hätten jetzt quasi die Werkzeuge alle da.
Die Pandemie quasi innerhalb von den nächsten zwei Wochen könnten wir die quasi beenden. Theoretisch.
Praktisch auch, nur nicht realistischerweise, weil, wissen wir ja, so.
Und in dem Rahmen muss man jetzt halt irgendwie argumentieren und ich kann viele Seiten verstehen und ich bin persönlich natürlich sehr viel näher an der,
Ja Leute, ihr habt jetzt alle die Chancen gehabt, die Fakten liegen auf dem Tisch. Äh so kann's nicht weitergehen. Wenn ihr nicht bereit seid, äh in eurem Bereich äh ein ein Schutzraum zu eröffnen, dann,
eröffnen wir es in die Leute, die eben bereit sind sich und andere zu schützen. Dann machen wir halt einen Schutzraum, aber seid ihr das Problem.
Das ist quasi ein selbstgewähltes Ding so, ne? Und.
Wir kennen grade, was weiß ich, auch im Fußball ist das auch so eine so eine so eine Debatte, wo wo du dann natürlich auch ähm als Veranstalter immer so ein bisschen in äh vor dieser Problematik stehst.
Klar könntest du jetzt eine Entscheidung fällen pro Schutz. Ja?
Kongress, jetzt Jahresende gab's ja auch, die Debatte soll ja jetzt stattfinden oder nicht, hätte der stattgefunden, hätte dort auch genau diese Entscheidung gefällt werden müssen.
Sagst du einfach nö, wir konzentrieren uns jetzt hier quasi auf die, die die bereit sind da mitzumachen. Ja und die anderen, die nicht bereit sind da mitzumachen,
Die lassen wir dann halt einfach außen raus. So. Da kann man natürlich sagen, ja klar, rationales Argument und so äh müssen ja alle nachvollziehen, aber was du halt so oder so machst, ist, dass du so einen Keil
in deine eigene Community reinschiebst und sagst, du kommst damit mal klar.
Und damit wird die Community irgendwie nicht klarkommen und das bei Fußballvereinen so. Es bei vielen anderen Vereinen so, dass es sind Fragestellungen, die sich wahrscheinlich auch.
Messen ein Stück weit, na ja, ich würde jetzt mal eher so von so Umgebungen reden, wo quasi auch eine eine über Jahre gewachsene Gemeinschaft regelmäßig zusammenkommt. Ne, auch,
dein Motorradclub,
auch so ein so ein Beispiel, wenn natürlich auch sehr viel kleiner in der Skalierung so, dass er halt auch immer dieses Problem hast, dass diese Maßnahmen.
Irgendwo einen Keil reinschieben und du sich dann fragen musst, welcher Fallout ist für mich problematischer. Der Infektionsvollout.
Der Freiheitsverlust für Leute, die eigentlich.
Alles in ihren äh Möglichkeiten äh stehende getan haben.
Die Situation zu verbessern ja oder ist der Vollhaut der Leute, die dazu aus welchen Gründen auch immer nicht bereit sind, die dann auch noch mit zu verlieren.
Weil es ja dann auch schnell so ein Wir versus die ist und so eine.
Gut böse Verteilung auf einmal da reinkommt, die man ja eigentlich so.
Auch nicht sein will, weil das ist ja letzten Endes auch nur eine Entscheidung in diesem einen Thema. Sicherlich ein wichtiges Thema, aber es gibt ja auch andere Themen, wo diese Gruppen sich nicht.
In die eine oder in die andere Gruppe teilen sollen, wo dieser Graben oder diese Mauer dann woanders äh verläuft und das ja, das ist einfach schwierig.
Also um's vielleicht mal bisschen zu vereinfachen, weil alles irgendwie super kompliziert äh war, aber am Ende.
Okay, erstmal wenn die Intensivstation voll laufen.
Wenn die Krankenhäuser voll laufen, dann äh wird's halt wieder einen Lockdown geben.
Ja, da führt da könnte jeder jetzt sagen, was er will, aber wir können halt äh den
äh völligen Zusammenbruch des Gesundheitssystems nicht riskieren äh wir brauchen unsere Intensivstation im Moment für 80 Prozent andere Patienten
die sonst
sterben, ja, da kommen irgendwie noch wenn wenn wir die nicht behandeln können, ja, die aus anderen Gründen intensivpflichtig sind auf einmal, ja. Dann reden wir nochmal von von ganz anderen
sekundär so. Also mit anderen Worten so Zusammenbruch äh geht halt nicht. Das heißt,
irgendeinem Punkt, wenn man's jetzt einfach laufen lässt und äh sich das nicht entweder selbst limitiert.
Oder weggeboostert wird so, dann wird's einen Lockdown geben. So sieht die Logik aus, weil Lockdown ist das Einzige.
Von dem wir wissen, ähm dass es funktioniert ja ähm.
Und äh ja äh auf der anderen Seite, äh wenn mir natürlich auch wissen,
je höher die Zahlen jetzt steigen, umso vorsichtiger werden die Leute auch. Das heißt, die Kneipen werden auch Lehrer äh viele Leute passen halb mehr auf und reduzieren dann von sich aus die Kontakte und
irgendwie passen Masken tragen und generell, ich sage mal, äh finde ich, ist die Maskendisziplin äh ähm
nach wie vor recht gut äh so. Aber es scheint halt,
im in der Summe im Moment nicht nicht zu reichen. Es gibt offenbar zu viele dann auch maskenlose Begegnungen, aber das wird halt auch auch zu nehmen. Ähm.
Ja ähm in und wenn wir halt das,
vermeiden wollen so, dann äh gibt's halt nur das Wegbus dann. Also wenn wir andere Einschränkungen vermeiden wollen und äh und da,
Dann wieder an dem Punkt, dass wir bei,
dem Rest der Leute dem Schalter im Kopf äh umlegen müssen, sodass sie dann einen Impfzentrum aufsuchen und sich impfen lassen oder
oder ihren ihren Arzt so. Und wie wir diesen Schalter umgelegt kriegen, ja, das ist das ist die die sagen,
eigentliche Frage oder das eigentliche Dilemma, ob äh mit mit Druck, mit Unbequemlichkeiten, mit,
Ausgrenzung mit Belohnung ähm ja ähm,
ein vermutlich sollte man.
Alles gleichzeitig äh machen oder gucken zumindest was was funktioniert und auch auf andere Länder schauen, Portugal hat
hat es ja auch glaube ich ziemlich gut hingekriegt, eine extrem hohe Impfquote hinzukriegen. Bremen hat mir vorhin schon erwähnt. Also ähm wir sehen es,
Es geht, es es gibt halt Maßnahmen und ähm im Moment, glaube ich, wird da auch nicht aber nicht wirklich gepusht oder siehst du irgendwo jetzt von staatlicher äh Seite
aus jetzt äh besondere Aktivitäten, um hm ja die Leute zum Impfen,
anzuhalten, gerade ähm.
Nö, überhaupt nicht. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Also es wird viel zu wenig darüber geredet. Klar, es gibt so, ja lassen sich impfen und so weiter. Aber was es braucht, gucke mal, in in Israel.
Rufen die Gesundheitsbehörden jeden an oder schreiben Briefe, wenn man grad nicht ganz so sicher, ich glaube es sind sogar Anrufe. Ja, guten Tag, äh ich bin hier um den Termin für ihre Dritte Impfung.
Mit ihnen abzumachen. Also eine unmittelbare, direkte Ansprache. In Deutschland gab's da noch nicht mal einen Brief an alle.
Also kann ich mich jetzt nicht dran erinnern, gab doch ganz am Anfang gab's mal irgendwas, oder?
Es gab dann Briefaktionen. Ja, aber.
Das war mir so Verständnis für die Situation und lalala, aber zum Impfen gab's nix. Es gab halt,
In manchen Ländern wie in Berlin, am Anfang um den Mangel zu verwalten, gab's so Benachrichtigungsschreiben mit jetzt können sie sich einen Termin klicken.
Aber das wird dich mal konsequent äh,
Aufklärung betrieben wird. Wo ist denn das Lea irgendwie? Was was was an alle verschickt wird, wo mal drinsteht, was eigentlich Sache ist.
Existiert doch gar nicht, also noch nicht mal noch nicht mal so ein Booklet äh hat diese Bundesregierung auf eine Kette bekommen, die man einfach mal an alle,
Briefkästen reinschmeißt, das muss ja noch nicht mal adressiert sein, einfach Postwurfsendung, wie die Bildzeitung das aufmacht, zack
hier jeder äh jede Briefträgerin, jeder Briefträger zack, bum, hier ist eure äh Kiste, schmeiß rein, egal was das kostet. Und da steht dann alles drauf, mit Telefonnummern, wann, wo, wie, warum zack, fertig. Ändert sich. Gleich noch mal.
Überhaupt gar kein großes Problem gewesen.
Oder äh tatsächlich Leute,
rumschicken, die entweder telefonieren oder an der Haustür klingeln. Ich meine, für die fucking Volkszählung haben wir's auch hingekriegt, ja,
dass irgendwie äh äh an jeder Haustür geklingelt wird, zumindest bei der bei der ersten haben wir's hinbekommen, weil ich war da selber als Schüler, als Volkszähler unterwegs äh so
Gab damals irgendwie fünf Mark pro Interview äh äh was man dann geführt hat, ja. Ähm gut, ich meine,
Was ja,
Das wäre wahrscheinlich dann auch eine eine Empfehlung oder eine Idee, einfach Leute,
in größeren Mengen
rumzuschicken oder ich meine, für politische Kampagnen, ja? Äh äh werden alle möglichen dann immer Künstler und
äh Fußballer und ähm wer auch immer äh äh Promis rekrutiert, äh die dann quasi als Botschafter Werbung machen, weil das nun mal auch viele Leute sind. Wo, ja, wo bleibt.
Gab's also es gab so Promi-Werbung auf Plakaten, Bahnhöfen und so weiter, so was gab's.
Mhm. Okay, ansatzweise, aber.
Das war's dann aber auch schon.
Aber äh ja, das müsste eigentlich bei einer ja Pandemie, die unser aller Leben äh gerade auf den Kopf stellt, müsste es ja hier auch möglich sein.
Sagen, was im Wahlkampf möglich ist, ja, an Propaganda aufzufahren.
Ja von von staatlicher Seite erst recht, ja? Ähm.
Ja, dann meinen haben wir doch schon irgendwie jetzt jetzt hier noch in der Sendung ein ganz ganz gutes äh,
Arsenal an an Empfehlungen äh erarbeitet jetzt äh interaktiv. Also ich glaube mal zusammen äh zu fassen äh so ähm.
Ja äh man muss die Leute dazu bringen
dass sie sich impfen lassen und dazu gibt es eine Vielzahl von Maßnahmen, äh die möglich wären und derzeit,
ergriffen worden sind von, ich sage mal direkter Ansprache über nochmal Senkung der Schwellen, man kann sogar, so wie ich, erwähnt hatten, was weiß ich, mit Lotterie.
In Verbindung mit Lotterie, um auch so eine bestimmte Gruppe äh zu kriegen, die dafür äh ansprechbar ist über
alle möglichen medialen äh Kanäle, über Promis, über ja also ähm.
Über ganz, ganz, ganz viele Wege. So äh äh letztlich äh müssen die Leute dazu bringen, äh sich impfen und Boostern äh zu lassen jetzt, weil sonst gibt's halt,
Einschränkungen wieder äh und äh Probleme mit der Wirtschaft und äh ja tausend tausend andere äh Dinge, Tote, Kranke, äh,
ja
Und noch mehr Podcasts von uns.
Und ah wir müssen und und ja genau.
Das Problem gibt's auch noch.
Ich würde mich wirklich langsam gerne irgendwie mehr anderen Themen zuwenden wollen.
Arsch hoch. Genau.
Aber äh ja.
Na gut, lass es uns äh an der Stelle mal ähm zu Ende bringen
Ich denke, jetzt haben wir genug ähm nachgedacht und äh wir freuen uns auch über eure Kommentare zu dem Thema. Es gibt hier nicht die eine Lösung, ne, mit der man das jetzt hier irgendwie alles geregelt bekommt, aber ich denke, was klar wird, ist
Muss geschehen. So und es braucht einfach mal eine aktivere Ansprache, um die Impfsituation zu lockern. Da muss einfach hinterhergegangen werden. Es muss einfach mal
Tief des Impfen,
befördert werden, noch mehr mobile Impfteams und nicht die Impfteams einstellen, wie es derzeit stattfindet. Impfzentren offen halten oder teilweise wieder eröffnen.
Grippeimpfung, ja, ist jetzt zum Beispiel auch ein Thema und es heißt Grippeimpfung, Coronaimpfung gleichzeitig, alles kein Problem.
Warum machen denn die Impfzentren nicht auch einfach mal Grippeimpfungen? Es hätte jetzt eigentlich so ein großer Unterschied.
Sowieso schon ganz viele Ärzte rumlaufen. Okay, man muss dann die Logistik mit nochmal anderen Impfstoff und so, aber ich glaube, wenn sie jetzt eine Arztpraxis hinkriegen, sollte man das im Impfzentrum eigentlich auch noch hinbekommen. Man könnte halt auch die Grippeimpfung gleich noch zusätzlich mit anbieten.
Wird auch nicht auch nur ansatzweise diskutiert dieser Fall. Und das ist das halt, was mich einfach stört. Das ist einfach niemand sitzt im Sattel, niemand fühlt sich auch irgendwie halbwegs verantwortlich, außer vielleicht Karl Lauterbach,
so als als Abgeordneter aus der zweiten Reihe die ganze Zeit eigentlich äh sagt, was was was Phase ist, der wahrscheinlich auch der einzige ist im ganzen Bundestag, der überhaupt was versteht von dem ganzen Quatsch.
Jetzt noch nicht mal als Gesundheitsminister im Gespräch ist, frage ich mich ja auch irgendwie, was was ist eigentlich bei euch kaputt? Irgendwie so, ja? Wäre jetzt mal echt ein Move, der was bringen.
Zu ihm stehen, wie man will so, aber man zumindest in irgendeiner Form da mal äh in die Front äh stellen wäre sicherlich äh angemessen.
Nicht so begeistert von.
Nein, das das das Ding ist, dass leider ähm ähm so, ich ich erkenne musste, dass äh in der Politik halt selber denken, nicht so gefragt ist.
Ist mir schon klar. Ich meine, das das ist ja das Dilemma, was ich gerade anspreche. Also es ist halt einfach keiner bereit, Verantwortung zu übernehmen
haben wir jetzt schon das ganze Jahr über. Das das haben wir schon wunderbar mit mit dem Ende der zweiten Welle gesehen, so wo sie dann alle nur Öffnungen, Öffnungen, Öffnungen geschrien haben und zack hatten wir die dritte Welle, ja da hätte schon mal alles sehr viel besser sein können und es wurde auch nicht gemacht, weil keiner bereit ist
Verantwortung zu übernehmen, weil keiner bereit ist wirklich sich mal hinzustellen und zu sagen, so wir ziehen das jetzt einfach mal durch. Wo wo ist wo ist die regelmäßig tagende
Corona-Gruppe, die einfach die ganze Zeit äh Maßnahmen.
Beschließt und einfach auch mal Sachen mal durchzieht. Ich sehe es einfach nicht. Und das ist schon ein totales Versäumnis.
Ja, also wir sind da institutionell suboptimal aufgestellt äh äh glaube ich. Ich meine äh wahrscheinlich besser als als viele andere Länder immer noch, aber ähm ja.
Aber äh deutlich äh suboptimal äh glaube ich und dass das greift alles auch irgendwie nicht so richtig ineinander und äh ja das ist alles irgendwie hat man das Gefühl so ein bisschen Stück
Werk und äh operiert halt alles auch sehr sehr,
langsam äh natürlich nach nach eigenen äh Regeln und äh ja ähm ich meine.
Was wir vielleicht auch mehr brauchen, sind gute Geschichten. So ähm,
positive Geschichten. Ähm so, aber äh das ist halt auch ganz, ganz äh.
Schwer heutzutage irgendwie ja äh Narrative zu finden, äh die sich die sich verbreiten in äh so einem,
ja äh medialen Informationsgetöse äh im Kampf um Aufmerksamkeit äh,
allen Richtungen ist es halt ja auch schwierig irgendwie potenziell Nachrichten äh äh durchzukriegen. Also es läuft glaube ich auch alles noch äh suboptimal.
Wobei ja die Medien, wenn man sich die anschaut, äh so muss muss man muss man sagen,
Ja sind die überwiegend okay, was man da, was man da zu lesen kriegt. Ja, im im Vergleich zu anderen Themen jetzt, so habe ich das Gefühl. Klar.
Äh
Da wir natürlich auch auch gesehen dann, wie dann bestimmte Leute oder Gruppen nach vorne gebracht wurden, um die eigene politische Agenda äh zu äh zu pushen, aber.
Ich glaube, wir sind jetzt gerade in einer anderen Situation. Also für mich fühlt sich die Situation ganz anders an, als äh vor einem vor einem Jahr.
Weil.
Irgendwie viele Dinge äh sind jetzt einerseits deutlich klarer, ja sowas was funktioniert und.
Was nicht und ähm die Situation ist nicht so,
bedrohlich wie vor einem Jahr
als wir eben noch keinen Impfstoff hatten. Das heißt, äh wir haben halt irgendwie immer noch diese, also es gibt jetzt diese Option. Wir wissen, wir können es in den Griff kriegen.
Wir wollen und wir werden es in den Griff kriegen, ja. So, deswegen ist man sagen diese oh,
Es könnte halt komplett außer Kontrolle geraten, äh diese diese Angst ähm so ist glaube ich nicht präsent und und,
auch tatsächlich äh nicht begründet, ja. Also es wird nicht völlig außer Kontrolle geraten, so das kann man auch,
sicher sagen, weil äh wie gesagt, entweder äh wird geimpft und geboostert und äh oder es wird halt äh ja isoliert. Ja.
Und Kontakte beschränkt.
Auf welche Art und Weise auch immer und wir wissen, dass das zum Erfolg führen wird oder zumindest verhindern wird, äh dass es jetzt völlig.
Außer Rand und Band gerät.
Und äh die optimale Lösung, glaube ich, werden wir auch wie in den vorangegangenen Wellen. Vermutlich nicht.
Erreichen. So, das äh ja.
Super. Haben wir da wieder einen schönen positiven Ausblick äh zum Ende hinbekommen. Klassiker.
Äh sorry. Ja, ja, ja. Aber ich ich fand, also ich fand den schon jetzt verhalten optimistisch, oder? Also wir werden's ja, also wir werden's.
Sind wir äh auf jeden Fall. Ich äh würde jetzt auch keine Panik verbreiten wollen.
Also wir wir werden's wieder verkacken, aber nicht völlig.
Damit ist jetzt wirklich alles gesagt.
Gut Leute, ähm.
Paar Themen haben wir noch auf der äh äh Liste gehabt. Das packen wir dann in die nächste äh Sendung. Das sind so die Sachen, die wollten wir jetzt hier erst mal loswerden. Wir beobachten natürlich die Situation weiter und dann.
Wann wir wieder zusammenkommen. Ähm würde sagen, sagen wir erstmal äh tschüss, oder?
Ja.